Hello!
Hello, hello, hello.
Oh, DVR is on.
I turned it off.
Thank you.
It's very rare that I start on the screen...
before a game.
But I'm eating dinner because I just got home.
I'm so sorry.
For VOD watchers, you probably don't care.
You're probably like, this doesn't pertain to me.
But for everybody else, I'm sorry.
I'm like an hour and a half late.
Because I...
I got a new car.
Woohoo!
Yippee!
I posted it...
I posted it in pre-chat.
I was like, I got a Cybertruck!
Oh yeah.
That's where your donos are going to.
Oh yeah, I got a Ferrari.
I got a Maserati.
I got a...
A body-ody.
But I was at the...
I was at the dealership for like...
A Bugatti!
many hours.
So I'm tired.
I like the difference between the two messages.
I'll give 10 if it's actually a Cybertruck.
Or Cybertruck, I'm cancelling.
No, obviously I'm not going to say what my actual new car is, but...
It's good.
I like it.
I was going to get a...
Oh my gosh, my voice is really bad today.
Did you get the Rex or the Ray?
I think it's more Rex than Ray.
Congrats on the new Cobra car, boss.
Thank you!
Yeah, it's a cardboard box.
What company is...
I'm not going to say anything!
Oh my gosh.
I won't even say the year, I'm too scared.
It is a used car though.
I will at least say that.
I did not get a new car.
I did get a used car.
But I was looking at another car.
I wonder if it's okay to say it.
Probably because it doesn't have any link.
You know?
Maybe.
But I was looking at another car.
And I actually...
Test drove it today.
And I was like...
Actually, I don't like this.
So...
I went with the car that I...
And the car that I got was cheaper anyway, so...
The car that I looked at initially would have been...
Would have been a new car.
And...
I have to name it.
Maybe...
Maybe I will name it Rex.
Does it fit 20 people?
Yeah.
Probably.
Thank you so much for that, Kazuma!
Thank you!
I got the Wienermobile.
Coming to a local...
Coming to your local town.
The Wienermobile.
Sorry, I didn't have a...
I didn't have time to eat.
Thank you so much for the 50!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted!
It's your birthday!
I can sing happy birthday.
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you guys.
Hold on.
Let me put down my fries.
Let me put down my fries and my fork.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Rodrigo!
Happy birthday.
Sorry, I think the drink I got is like messing up my throat.
So I have to get some tea after.
You say you're eating fries with a fork?
You don't?
I don't want to get my fingies dirty.
Dirty.
And also...
The chicken nuggies.
I don't want to get it on my keyboard.
You know...
Going to get a pliskinitasha?
Oh my gosh, I wish.
I wish!
Everyone would be like, wow.
That ghost scar is so cool.
No.
Who's that incredible hunk that's on that car?
He looks a little familiar.
No.
It couldn't be.
Is that Iroquois pliskin?
Of...
I don't remember what he said he's a part of.
The seals.
Yeah, I was like, it's a navy something, no?
I don't think he was a...
I don't think he... no.
He was...
He was not a marine.
But he said the Semper Fi, which was weird, right?
And that's why...
What's his name?
Cloctam.
Mr. Bomb Man.
Not Fat Man.
Other Bomb Man.
Yeah, he wasn't a marine, but he said Semper Fi.
Stillman.
Thank you.
I remember.
I know.
I know what I'm talking about.
Fake fan.
David, why are you not David anymore?
Why are you Dapen?
It was my birthday on Saturday, the day the collab cafe started.
You weren't streaming then.
Yeah, I was in Japan.
I can sing Happy Birthday.
Happy Birthday to you.
Happy Birthday, dear Blotch.
Happy Birthday.
I've always kind of wondered about that.
Like, why is Snake not...
no.
Like, was he not in the military?
Maybe he...
Because he was kind of born into it?
Maybe it's Maybelline?
He was an accountant.
I think he's just a little dumb.
I saw the photos from the collab cafe.
Oh, the food looks so good.
Will Yummy Mama be putting up extra merch for sale?
Yes, if you want the merch...
Actually, you can go to the cafe.
They will be putting up...
It's a...
Like, pre-order?
It's made...
Order to merch...
Wait, order...
Made to order!
It's made to order.
So, it won't, like, sell out or anything.
I imagine it will be for a limited amount of time.
And I will double confirm that time frame for you guys.
But...
Yes, it's made to order.
And so...
If you wanted any of the merch...
You could get it.
If you wanted to.
Oh!
You guys, did you watch the Silent Hill transmission?
Can we watch it together?
Together?
I saw that they showed off the new...
Silent Hill F.
And I wanna watch it.
Hold on real quick.
Let me get it up.
I'm a very slow eater.
I'm really sorry.
Especially when I'm talking.
So, I'm like...
I'll probably...
I'll just eat until I'm like...
Okay.
I'm really hungry.
I was getting hangry.
I was getting hangry at the place.
I was like...
I wanna eat.
Maybe this is okay.
Hold on, I'm pulling it up.
Sorry, guys.
Okay.
There.
And there.
Should be okay.
I don't want it cutting off anything.
There we go.
I haven't watched this yet.
But I really wanted to because, you know, the new...
I was gonna say the new Higurashi.
The new Silent Hill is...
Ryukishi.
So, Ryukishi 7.
So I was like...
This is my first full...
This is my first look.
I'm gonna...
Let's see.
That was the audio.
Actually, let me turn it up a little.
It looks so pretty.
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's so pretty.
Oh my god!
It's so pretty.
What in the fatal frame?
It's so...
I did see though that they based the location off of a real...
This picture I saw.
They based it off of a real place in Gifu.
Time to go.
Pilgrimage.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's so awesome.
Oh, I'm so...
Oh, I'm so obsessed.
What did she do to go to Silent Hill?
Hinako, what did you do?
Wait, there is a body there.
Didn't flush.
I'm not scared, I'm in love.
I love this so much already.
I love how this is not explaining anything.
It's not explaining anything.
It's just all aesthetics.
What is that flower called again?
It represents death.
Ew.
I'm eating.
Spider lily, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cue combat sequence.
Do we have a release date or anything?
I think so.
It looks so...
Oh my god.
I don't like that part.
Gross.
Fatal frame.
It's truly...
Oh my gosh.
Look at this visual.
It looks like fatal frame so much.
Ew.
Which honestly makes me the happiest.
I love fatal frame.
It's so pretty.
Hold on.
Let's go back to this lady.
I really liked her.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Sorry, I'm having...
It looks kind of mannequin-like.
So maybe it's supposed to be like the nurse.
Or I guess...
I guess there was like the mannequins and, you know, the other ones.
Yeah, doll-like.
Very cool.
Oh, it's so pretty.
So pretty.
It's too...
Oh, this thing too.
It's too pretty to be scary.
Nasty.
It's too pretty to be scary in my opinion, maybe.
Oh, going feral for this atmosphere.
Me too!
Oh my gosh.
So it doesn't...
No, we didn't get a...
Wait.
Wishlist now.
Wait, is this on Steam?
Steam, Steam, Steam, Steam, Steam, Steam, Steam, Steam.
Silent.
Oh, oh, it is.
Oh yeah.
Only PS5?
No, no.
I think it's because I watched it on Playstation's...
I watched it on their YouTube.
Actually Konami, not sponsored obviously, but Konami is doing a spring sale.
And like all the Metal Gear games are on sale if you wanted to pick them up.
It's on Steam, but they don't mention it on the trailer.
Could be, like I said, because it's a...
What do you call the Playstation trailer?
It looks so pretty.
What do you mean obviously?
Because it's like, I wouldn't...
I couldn't, I couldn't like do a sponsor in the middle of this keep driving stream.
That would be so silly.
Did you see the new DMC anime trailer?
I did, I did.
And yes, I did see the Death Stranding 2 trailer.
But...
Like I know that there's a guy that looks just like Snake.
And there's a machine that looks just like Rex.
But, because I haven't finished Death Stranding 1, I've been...
I've been mostly avoiding...
Any sort of like active watching of the trailers.
Because I don't want any kind of spoilers.
So, I do know that those things are in the trailer.
But I haven't like actively watched the trailer itself.
Just being like...
That guy looks just like Solid Snake.
No, that is not Solid Snake.
What if it's like...
What if he is like...
Hardened Asp.
And then, was there a release date for Death Stranding 2?
I saw some people saying this summer.
Do I have to...
Do I have to get my butt in gear and finish it?
June something.
June, oh no!
Okay.
I'm trying to decide if I want to stream Death Stranding or not.
Like the original.
Maybe.
I know it's like hard game to stream.
I don't really care so much about like...
Like being a viewership game.
Some games you just always want to do for yourself, you know?
It's chill.
We can play the music on stream now?
Oh yeah, because I don't care about copyright.
My streams get flagged.
My streams lose monetization all the time.
It's okay.
It's okay for the...
For the...
Like even this game.
Keep driving.
Last time, it got...
It got monetized flagged.
You know?
But I don't even think...
I don't even think I make like enough views to...
Really even affect...
You know?
For me to care.
Wasn't it because you turned off streamer mode?
Yeah, because I wanted us to listen to the music.
Obviously.
I would much rather have the vibes.
If they don't take super money, it's not that big of a deal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly, exactly.
Then I would be mad because it's like...
They'd be taking your money.
And that would upset me the most.
Is this Minto monetization?
The Minto monetization...
Network.
The M-M-N.
The mmm...
Mmm...
But yeah, I'm almost done with my food.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm almost done.
Well, I'm glad we could watch that trailer together.
Thank you for...
Someone mentioned Death Stranding and it made me think of this that I wanted.
I was like...
While I'm eating...
While I'm eating, I can...
Watch it with you guys.
Is there anything else you guys want to...
Anything else I should react to?
I'm a react channel real fast.
What am I eating?
I'm eating chicken nuggies.
And fries.
Minto, Beat Death Stranding on stream, my life is yours.
Thank you so much for the Haka Super.
Okay, maybe I will do it then.
Maybe I could do like a Death Stranding week or something, you know?
Maybe I could do something like that since...
It might be a better game to do like all at once.
Devil May Cry trailer?
Oh yeah, we can watch that.
Sorry I haven't caught a stream live in a while, but I'm always watching both.
Thank you!
It's my birthday today, but thank you for being bit...
Thank you Ix300!
Thank you!
Hold on, let me finish chewing.
Netflix takes down vids?
I was thinking just...
The...
The song in it.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Ix300!
Happy birthday!
Let's get rid of this now.
And I'll go back here now.
I will bring back the menu now.
And yeah.
Ever since the new model, Minto chewing has been 100 times cuter.
No!
I'm so self-conscious!
Stop!
No!
Don't watch me chewing!
But you can see I'm chewing with my mouth closed like a little lady.
Do you give your meals the maid cafe blessing?
Why would I?
I'm the source of the moe energy.
I'm the source of the deliciousness.
Wow, something is so delicious.
Where could it be coming from?
Right here.
Yummy, baby.
Moe moe cannibalism.
Yeah, why don't you guys...
Would you guys like to bless my fry that I'm about to eat from?
Right?
Moe moe bless you.
Moe moe cute!
OK, I'm going to try it now since you guys blessed it.
I'm going to try it!
It's going to be delicious.
Moe moe cute!
I'm going to try it.
Let's eat.
It's so yummy.
You guys did a great job.
I'm swallowing?
Yeah, let's not do that again ever, huh?
Let's not do that again.
You guys...
You'll get there.
You'll get there, I promise.
Maybe.
You just need to hone your powers.
Yeah, this is why I'm the main.
She's blessing on my moe to like you.
Thanks for being the wind beneath our wings.
What's that song called?
Is that the song you're referencing?
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the spooky donut!
Ken-san super chat while I'm in Japan apparently.
I wanted to say the cafe was awesome!
I'm going to miss stream while I fly back to Canada today.
I'm going to save flight today!
I know you're always looking for 1-2 stream games.
I saw a silly one called Thank Goodness You're Here.
Wait, I think I've heard that one before.
Oh, trip?
Thank you so much!
Hi Minto!
You started affecting my wardrobe.
All my skirts are turning green as a pink enjoyer.
My coworkers keep saying, Green today?
When they see the green hair scrunchie.
Is this a virus?
Oh my gosh, this happened to me before too.
With my OSGs I started collecting their colors.
And then I turned mint.
Oh my god!
The mint-o-virus.
Thank you so much for the hunk of silver!
That's so cute though.
One second.
Hello, RXRouter!
Thank you so much for the 10th gifted.
Happy birthday again!
My, my, my!
Thanks for 10 months.
Sarah's gifted?
Thanks for the 10th gifted.
Chouken, welcome to membership.
Salty because of our tears.
That might have been what ruined it.
Not ruined it, sorry.
That might have been what added the zesty flavor.
Johnny, thanks for the 10th gifted!
Thank you.
Sorry, Freudian slip.
Okay, and...
Gochisousama deshita!
All done with my dinner!
Thank you guys for allowing me to eat.
Suddenly turned into like a Zatsudan watch along.
Takeshiro, thanks for the 10th gifted!
Thank you!
No, no, I said not ruined.
I don't need to wash my hands because I used a fork.
Now I gotta...
Open the game.
Now I gotta open the game.
Steam.
What's this game called?
Driving.
Actually, I...
Why did I decide to play this game on the same day that I got a car?
I'm so sick of cars.
Casey Raptor, thanks for the 5th gifted!
Thank you.
Remember last time we found a cat?
Yes, that's where we ended!
We ended on the...
Oh shoot, hold on.
Taro and I were supposed to talk tonight.
Yeah, we ended because...
After we did the cat quest.
And I had to go find a cat.
Sometimes you just feel like hitting the road, you know?
At least they don't try to upsell you on this car.
True!
Minty, your YouTube DVR is on.
No, no, I turned it off.
You just need to refresh your page.
DVR is off.
Watching some Minto before my operation?
Routine?
Wait, operation?
Operation?
Are you okay?
Open game.
The music.
Oh god.
Wait, hold on.
Everything is almost up.
The game is all weird.
Hold on.
I'm fixing it.
I know you can't see anything.
You will, once I fix it.
Okay, hold on.
Then we go here.
Then we go game capture.
Then we do this.
And I got to get in a spot.
Where was I last time?
I think I was like...
Here?
About?
And then I can chop off my body.
Let me put my arms down.
Blasphemous.
Okay.
Sorry.
I can adjust.
Welcome everybody to Keep Driving!
You had that cute hat on last time.
I saw your tweet about that.
You like the sun hat, huh?
Wait.
How do I put it on?
It's like a little different.
Hold on.
I'm going to... Hold on.
I'll put it on.
Give me a second.
A little gas money.
Oh, thank you friend!
Stalker?
No!
Only sometimes.
Wait, hold on.
I got to find my hat.
Crash, crash, tick, tick, tick, crash.
Don't mind the noise in the background.
Don't mind.
I'm just searching.
I'm going through my things.
Don't mind it.
Oh, my leg!
Oh, don't mind.
Hat.
Sorry.
I forgot what I was looking for.
What?
Oh, hold on.
Hold on.
Wait.
Anybody who is curious what's going on, don't even worry your pretty little head about it.
Okay?
All is well that...
Oh, no.
I messed up.
No!
All is well that ends well, I think.
Right?
That's the saying.
Hold on.
I found the wrong hat.
I got to start over.
I got to clear the entire neighborhood.
Crash, crash.
Oh, it's on fire!
Oh, my god.
I had a family.
I can't believe it's all gone.
It's all gone.
Except my hat.
It's definitely underneath this pile.
Oh, my god.
Oh, the humanity.
Why is god so cruel?
Oh, my god.
I'll never...
I'll never work in this town again.
I can't figure it out.
Hold on.
Oh!
I might have figured it out.
Good enough.
Yippee!
Okay.
The world has been burnt down for this hat.
I just got here.
What's going on?
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Worse?
Really?
It's not... I don't think it looks as good as it did last time.
Sorry, because I'm on a...
I did it a little rushed, but you know.
Okay.
Keep driving.
Vroom, vroom.
We're continuing, baby, from the last time.
Oh.
How do I play this game again?
And we have...
We have a passenger and his dog.
That's right.
You drive the car.
And I have so much food!
We have a lot of food.
If I eat it...
Okay, we're tired.
And we're so show.
How's the audio, by the way?
Feel free to speak up if it's bad.
We have skill points and I haven't really used them.
What does it do?
Hold my beer.
How am I supposed to see what it does?
Oh, right click to see details.
I can read.
A little loud?
Is that better?
Changes target with... Okay, I'm starting to remember.
Remove all armor.
Destroy one threat.
For each armor lost.
What's this one?
Remove one threat.
Each skill used this event.
10 cash!
If you get a perfect with this skill, restore 1 use to all skills and gain 10 cash.
Oh, it costs cash but also you gain the cash.
Incredibly important.
Press space.
Space?
Get out of my way!
1 gas.
3 uses.
1 energy.
If you get a perfect with this skill, gain 1 gas.
I have so many...
I don't know.
Everything doesn't seem like it's so good.
Am I crazy?
I do have a good amount of money but...
Maybe this one.
Get a perfect.
Adapt has infinite uses.
Which one is Adapt?
Adapt.
Drive fast.
Oh yeah, it does.
Costs 0 energy.
Change targets with current... Oh, this one.
Adapt.
Eco driving under driving.
We're good in my experience.
Eco driving.
3 uses.
Costs 1 energy.
You know what?
Why not?
But I don't have space.
I'll just have it for now.
So, we just...
We just...
finished something.
We finished the cat.
And...
We're all the way in Fardorf.
That's craziness.
We gotta get all the way...
over to the festival.
There's a lot going on here.
We're two towns in.
I wish I could zoom in and out.
Yeah, we're literally...
home.
Fardorf.
But I'm gonna actually sleep.
So that we can be all rested and well.
Especially when we get ambushed on the streets.
Wow, we got a lot of things.
We're cold.
Okay, hold on.
Enter the food.
We can probably get a hot coffee.
And use.
Nice.
And eat a berry.
And we're fine now.
How about...
We do also have other...
Sorry, I keep going to the journal.
We have other things.
The great race.
Install a roll cage.
Get to the race.
Enter the race.
Punk club.
Go to the eastern city and find the club.
Oh, this is right.
Our grandma is dying.
I don't think we're gonna make it to her in time.
Race and inheritance are endings?
Well, we're definitely missing that one.
Let's get to the punk club.
Eastern city.
We're losing out on all the money.
No worries.
Eastern...
There's the race track.
Eastern city.
Oh my gosh.
This is what my mouse is doing, you guys.
You see this?
Meadows town.
I think this is where grandma is.
Rest in peace, grandma.
Oh my god, I can't track.
You see this?
Something's really wrong with my mouse recently.
Where is eastern city?
This is on the west, so I imagine it's on the east.
Thanks Ducky!
Can you click the map in the log?
Let's try it.
Go to the eastern...
Oh, there we go.
Oh, it's Hongad.
Okay, we gotta go all the way over there.
I guess it doesn't really matter.
We can go to Hongad.
Werewolf Aso.
Just unplugging the dongle once fixed it.
Maybe I need to do that.
Because I don't imagine it would break while I wasn't using it in Japan, you know?
Wouldn't that be so silly?
Oh, Hitchhiker Argument.
Dang it, I got so excited.
Why are we always fighting?
I think we need to kick this guy out.
I think we need to kick him out.
Can we keep the dog?
That might be the source.
Ouch.
There's a door, yeah.
I'm opening it up.
I'm kicking his butt out.
I do like the dog though.
I would like to keep him.
Warzoi.
What?
Oh my god!
Guys, we are in trouble.
Wait.
Guys, I'm a little scared.
Oh no, my mouse is making it hard.
Ok, there we go.
Add one durability threat.
Oh my god, they are surrounding us.
What do we do?
Oh, let's see, hold on.
Oh, thank goodness it worked.
You're scared.
I'm stressed, I'm stressing.
Please, please pick up.
There we go.
And...
I don't think this will... This one adapts forever though.
We did it!
Holy moly.
That stressed me out.
Hold over by car.
Why is the world...
Officer, thank goodness you're here.
I was just surrounded by a biker gang.
Please officer, you have to help me.
You have to help me.
Officer, officer, I'm innocent.
Officer, I'm innocent.
You have to help me.
Something tells me I'm gonna owe a lot of money.
What does the punk do?
Oh yeah, that's a good... Oh my gosh, please!
Oh my gosh!
You guys can see how bad my mouse is in full force here.
Remove left and right most threat.
Incur a random negative status.
Remove three random threats!
Of course he keeps the money.
Wait, does this cost anything?
Did this cost anything?
Ghost needs a new mouse.
Oh, it costs one gas.
What does the dog do?
I just spent so much on a car.
I don't want to get a mouse too.
Let me see...
My car... Not my car.
My mouse is hardwired right now.
Let me see, hold on.
I'm being introspective.
I hope I never become a commuter.
But I hope I become responsible.
But I hope I don't become boring.
But I hope I'll be happy.
Don't close your eyes on the road.
Or maybe.
What happens?
Two seconds go by.
They feel long and frightening.
Then you open them again.
That was scary.
Hi man, thank you for almost a year.
Thank you!
Thank you for being around for 11 months.
Speed cameras, what the heck.
This is like the longest road ever.
Hi Mito, yesterday I sent a bamboo ship saying it was my birthday.
And if you missed it, that's totally fine.
I think I did, I'm so sorry.
Matusi.
I was wondering if I did something wrong.
Oh, no.
No, it wasn't you.
It's not you, it's me.
But of course, let me get through this and then I'll wish you a happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Matusi.
I hope I'm saying your name right.
Happy birthday to you.
Moose... Oh, I thought that said moose fun.
But your name is Invisible Moose.
I thought it was a moose fun.
Hold on, let me unplug my dongle.
Thank you for the pings!
Thank you!
The punk has reached level 3.
Moose fun.
I wonder if the roads get longer.
Like, the more you play.
End zone.
Oh, we got a social.
We upgraded our social link.
The merch I bought finally came in!
I need suggestions on where to put the sticker I got.
The sticker is of a rear view.
Well, clearly I'm in the car then, right?
Welcome back.
Thanks, Goa!
Restore one use to each hitchhiker skill.
Oh, I'm gonna get that.
Actually, I don't have any space.
I'm so silly.
Hold on.
Let's go.
Oh wait, it's our guy.
He's right there.
Talk to him.
Try playing this sometime.
It's by this local band.
Mundane.
He literally just gave me his mixtape.
He just gave me his mixtape.
Oh man, we have such a lame...
We have such a lame hitchhiker.
I was gonna say friend, but this guy is definitely more foe than friend.
Find an item.
Wait.
I don't think...
We are in the spooky woods.
Into the woods.
Slenderman doko.
Collect 8 pages.
That would be terrifying if it was just like...
Hey, by the way.
Collect 8 pages.
Too scary.
Why are there so many abandoned...
I think it's the abandoned tent that scares me the most.
Does that not freak you guys out?
It's definitely a dead person's tent.
Why else would you leave it?
Is that everything?
We didn't go this way.
Now this looks modern and well taken care of.
Watch your energy.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
Thank you.
I just noticed it.
Yay.
What did we get?
Cool shades!
We got some skirts.
Skirts, skirts.
We got some more ciggies.
We got caffeine.
Caffeine pills.
Pills here.
Scrap.
We're gonna sell that.
Spilled beer.
We'll sell that.
Wine.
I'm definitely not using that.
I've learned my lesson.
And a rope.
Probably from that...
From that one camp.
Oh, here we go.
Awesome.
From the one tent.
Took the day off for road tripping with a vehicle.
No, why would you do that?
Oh, here's a...
Looking for an extra with a black car.
I don't have a black car.
Is there a car shop here?
We could maybe make our car black.
I'm selling the wine.
I don't care.
Wait, the skirt seems pretty good, no?
Nice teaspoon.
Wait, what does this do?
Increases durability by 2.
This is so much better.
There we go.
Yeah!
Increases durability.
We get the durability and we get the gas increase.
Nice.
In fact, I'm just gonna sell this one then.
The fender?
Goodbye.
Oh, wait.
We could do!
We could make our car black.
And then we could do that side quest.
Nice boost.
Nice, nice.
Hmm...
I think my car was okay.
So...
Did you get paid for the sponsorship side quest?
Yes!
Yes, so I honestly... I think it would be okay then.
Black spray...
Customize and...
This, right?
Wait, how do I use it?
Do it.
Oh, here.
I guess we can take this off then too.
The energy drink.
Nice.
Okay, modders might let you away to drive, Itasha.
That would be so awesome.
What's this?
Oh.
This is our only one, so...
Except...
Have a black car.
That's what we got, baby.
I don't need any more food.
But...
A hot tea would be nice.
My energy is...
Probably...
Probably next place will...
Will...
Do more...
Oh, awesome!
We are on the way!
Here we gotta go to the R64, so we just gotta go down that way.
Wait, R77.
Is that the next one?
Yes.
Let's go.
Nice.
Looks like a Yakuza card.
What?
I was reading an interesting book.
It was about a gorilla explaining the woes of humanity.
Or at least civilized humanity and how we just don't know how to live.
How should we live?
I don't know.
I haven't finished it.
But I think we are supposed to live more primitively or something.
I'm way ahead of you.
Artoons?
Flat tire?
No.
Hold on.
I think...
I think if I do this...
Nice.
And then this.
Oh my gosh.
My mouse, you guys.
This is so bad.
I really like my mouse too.
I don't want it to be...
I don't want it to be dead.
Flat tire for the flat ghost.
I, I, I...
But also I just realized we are going to have to sleep because we are going to lose our...
Our other abilities and all.
Remove left and right most threat.
I mean...
Three random threat.
Oh, let's do...
Oh, I was going to say let's do the cigarette.
I'm stupid.
This is such a cool roguelike.
Right?
It's fun.
It's really neat.
I don't know which one to... I don't know what to do.
Maybe your mouse ball is all gumped up.
My mouse ball?
Sorry, I was blowing in it.
I was blowing in the hole.
No, my mouse is pretty new.
Check out darkest dungeon.
Is that actually a chill game?
I think I'm going to do this one because we have two left on it.
I think we'll have one left on it and then we'll have the other one.
Sorry about the smell.
This...
It's not chill.
I was going to say, I don't think it is.
How do I put on the tunes?
Oh, music.
Here we go.
Eject.
And then we got mundane.
I think I remember liking the west... west whatever.
Play.
Abandoned... Oh, we can get something from this.
This is good.
It might have loot.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
This adapt is actually so good.
Adapt is actually so good.
And we have so many cigarettes.
I don't mind using them.
I have a smoking problem maybe.
West coast literally means west coast by the way.
Oh, I learned.
Suspension.
And some more scrap we can sell.
We'll rotate you.
And stick you right in there.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Those things will kill me with the smokes?
No, I'm gonna eat them.
I'm gonna have them in my tummy.
That's what I learned from Metal Gear.
We'll stop.
Is that a woman?
Hey!
Wow!
You're not an old trucker.
Where are you going?
You got room for me?
I'm just sort of traveling around.
Look out!
Put her in the back.
I have too many berries.
Do you think she'd be fine next to the porn?
I think she and the dog could share a seat, no?
Wait.
I have too many berries.
Oh no.
I can't make room for women.
I have too many berries.
Mambo, do you mind holding all my berries?
Eat them or sell them?
Even still, I don't think we'll have room, no?
I can't tell.
We have a lot of pizza.
What do I do with all my berries?
I don't want to waste food.
Food or...
What does she even do?
Oh wow!
Basic targeting skill.
Become inspired and tired.
She's flirting with me.
What do I do?
Wow!
Damn!
Thank you so much for the hocus pocus.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for singing Orange the other day.
It's one of my favorite songs from one of my favorite shows.
Me too!
I've been sick all week, but watching you has made me feel a lot better.
Today is my birthday!
I wanted to treat myself by treating you.
Yasashii sekai!
What the heck.
Thank you!
Of course, I will sing happy birthday for you too!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Tim.
Happy birthday and feel better.
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much.
You should be spoiling yourself.
If you like west coast, I can recommend you Tokyo Shoe Gazer.
Oh my gosh!
I know it's kind of memed upon, but I unironically like Shoe Gazer.
Okay, we'll eat the berries, you guys.
We'll eat our berries.
Do you think we're gonna get a status effect that is tummy ache?
Oh no!
I ate too many berries.
Tummy hurt.
Tummy hurt, too many berries.
Oh no!
Wait.
Hold on, we're almost there.
What?
I thought I was able to...
Oh wait, I think I still...
Hold on.
Dude.
Guys, I don't know if it's possible.
The radiator.
Goodbye, chips.
Hello?
No!
Wait, no!
Let's move everything up.
And free up this seat instead.
Why won't it lift?
Right click to raise.
I couldn't read.
Alright, let's accept woman.
Alright, nice.
We're all good!
Let's take a choco in the...
Oh, in the glove box.
Where are you headed anyway?
Gonna meet some friends.
Cool, me too.
Oh, what's happening?
In the zone.
We are also...
I'm sorry, did that just say hungry?
You liar of a game!
We are not hungry.
I ate so many berries!
That is such a lie!
That's an absolute lie.
Canned beans!
Alright, now we can sell off some of this stuff though.
So that's good.
Let's sell off our scrap.
Let's sell off this...
Oh, not the beans.
I might have to get like a new mouse tomorrow.
Maybe I'll order something, I don't know.
The berries were so good you got hungry?
I guess it's not like a full meal, huh?
I'm gonna sell my monster energy.
Radiator.
What is this?
Oh, bandage!
I don't really understand...
Oh, removes threat warnings.
Fruit candy.
In fact, I'm gonna buy the bandages.
I think that might be handy.
Oh, what's this?
Makes you immune to the stress status.
Ooh!
I like my mouse so much though.
I'll troubleshoot it.
I feel like I have to start getting rid of some of these...
Some of these...
Things that I probably am not gonna use.
Like some of these mechanic stuff.
Did you rhyme on purpose?
I rhymed?
I'm just a genius.
Don't you know that already?
Don't you know that by now?
So much food and still hunger.
I ate the banana, no?
Aspirin.
We have two things of aspirin.
We got two jerry cans.
Oh, wait.
I could use this.
And now we can sell it.
So that gives us a little bit more room too.
That gives us a little bit more room.
Let's see.
I don't think there was a mechanic in this town, so...
But we have a little bit of space.
You're gonna sell the doujin?
No!
These are my prized possessions.
I just realized also, I'm so sorry you guys.
My head has been like so in the way.
Oh, we can sell our sunglasses.
But they're kinda cool.
I don't wanna sell them.
Let's check.
Yeah, I was right.
There's only...
There's only a gas station.
18 bucks?
Sure.
We're about to get paid.
We're on the road...
to...
R64.
Another birthday!
Oh my goodness.
It's my friend's birthday today.
Can you wish Daniel a happy birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, damn Daniel.
Happy birthday!
Speaking of doujin, would you know where I can buy Ayami-sensei's books during my trip to Japan?
You could go to Melon Books if they have any.
Or you could go to places that have used doujinshi.
And see if there's anything there.
Though those places are kinda hard to look through because they don't really sort by anything.
So...
Might be kinda difficult.
Driving on the motorway sure is monotonous.
I'm looking forward to seeing something new.
It could be anything!
Could be.
Yeah guys, I gotta use doujin sometimes.
Flat tire again.
I say used, but it's like...
How to describe?
It's like...
It's like a...
It's more like a...
It doesn't always mean that it's been opened.
Yeah, second hand.
Pre-owned!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pre-owned.
What does lady do?
Oh that's right, we become inspired and tired.
I like this song a lot.
This is this one.
And this one.
Oh, this might be a mistake, but we'll see.
Detroit!
Why are you guys spoiling me so much today?
What is happening?
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Why?
Oh, more introspection.
How did my fingernails get so dirty?
I guess I've been scratching my head again.
I don't care.
I don't care!
You look at the road and stop thinking about your nails.
Oh, we're already here.
We got to the set.
Nice.
Hello!
Wow, that is just the kind of car we need.
Yippee!
We got paid, baby.
We got paid.
There's not much here either.
Ducky, they give her the five gift.
Thank you!
I kind of want this steering wheel sleeve.
What is this?
Oh, beer case.
No, no, no!
Don't do it.
I think my current cool shades are cooler than these cool shades.
Beer clock.
No!
That ruined... That ended... That killed the run before!
That's what killed our run.
I wish the rotating was not as bad.
Because I clearly can rotate it.
You just don't want to.
No!
We don't need anything.
Let's upgrade.
Oh, here.
Yeah, we need to go there.
But it's funny.
Do it for the heehee.
Do it for the haha.
Sell the magazines?
No, they're for me.
They're for myself.
Cute.
Ah, me baby.
My precious.
Only one way to go.
Kotsuke!
Can we see?
I'm gonna move over just a little bit too.
What else will we do?
Oh wait, I was gonna sleep here.
That's right.
Hold on.
Not leave, not leave.
Zoom.
I was gonna sleep.
What else would we do on the road if we didn't have our magazines, you know?
Eat the banana.
Alright.
We're set to go baby.
Let's go.
How has it almost been a year?
I don't know.
I can't believe it.
I've seen fairies.
They had wispy white hair and rode on frogs.
I'm not a fairy.
I'm a ghost by the way.
In case you were wondering.
Fallen tree?
Oh my gosh, I think that does not just... Everybody's driving.
Just everybody's driving through it.
Oh wow.
Wowee, wowee.
Let's do this one.
Do that and then I'm gonna use his skill and we're gonna remove three random threats.
And that.
Oh, I was gonna say that should be it but it wasn't.
Fairies aren't real.
Yeah, fairies aren't real.
What does this symbol mean again?
I don't remember.
Music one, clear adjacent threats.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
This would be a perfect game to teach you about managed stress while driving.
Alcohol, gambling apps, road rage, the good stuff.
What gambling apps are you... What are you playing?
Oh, hitchhiker argument.
I was gonna say another hitchhiker.
Oh, come on you guys.
Guys, we were in the groove, no?
We were in the groove.
Why are you guys arguing?
I'm inspired.
Oh, and I'm tired.
Goodbye cigarettes.
I really like this music.
Flat tire.
Let's also go into my... Oh, I can't go into my trunk, can I?
Oopsie.
Nice.
Ouchie ouch.
The dog has abilities now too?
Wait, serious?
Oh, my bark!
Red Carpenter, Turbo Killer would be my road trip music at night.
I've never heard it.
My road trip music is, at night especially, is a lot of Yuru Meru Mori songs.
Have you ever heard of them?
They're an idol group.
I don't... They're still around technically, but I don't really listen to their new lineup of people.
But...
They kind of have... Some of their songs have a bit of a shoegazy vibe, which I like.
I like the dog.
Oh, we can stay here.
We can stay at a nice hotel.
What else is here?
We can explore in the dark.
Oh, here we go.
Customize.
Alrighty.
What things do we got?
Suspension.
I already have a suspension.
Double the effect of your equipped wheels.
So I'm gonna sell this one.
Need it to be able to drive.
Remove one cash threat.
Remove one gas threat.
Remove one durability threat.
Do we want to have more armor, or do we want to remove a threat?
Either seems pretty nice, not gonna lie.
We'll keep the rope, because I don't know what we need it for, but...
This thing reduces gas drained on motorways.
This one technically I guess gives... Actually...
Armor is good all around.
Yeah, it gives us technically two armor, so it's even better.
And then... radiator.
Where does this go into?
Oh, where our skirt is.
Which I think I'm just gonna sell the radiator, because...
The skirt is too good.
Goodbye radiator.
And then the heater.
That goes there.
This is...
More durability and protects against sunlight.
I think I'll sell this too.
We won't get cold.
Just put on a jacket, duh.
I'll keep the exhaust pipe for now.
Discount at gas stations.
I'm selling stuff.
I'm making room.
Your shades already do that.
What, the sunlight?
Oh.
Oh, we get the two more durability.
That's big.
And look how big these are for me.
Superliminal, thank you so much for the 10 gifts!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you for being a friend.
I'm back again.
This should be okay.
Probably.
Oh.
Yeah, probably.
Probably.
How many more do I have?
Four out of six.
Okay, we're good on that.
Golden Minky.
Let's go exploring.
This seems not very safe.
This is not very safe at all.
I used the rope to climb!
That's what it's for!
Oh, wow.
Oh.
Interesting.
Oh, there's like nothing here though.
I imagine it's not a one-time use.
Snake eater.
What do you mean by that?
Because we're in the Russian jungles?
It's permanent?
Awesome.
Wow, this area is humungo.
I won't get lost.
We're even going through caves in the dark?
Are we insane?
I'm watching my energy.
We're gonna go to sleep after this, so it should be okay.
Minus one energy.
Wait, I did this one.
Is there a jump scare?
No, I don't think so.
We haven't gotten one yet.
I'm officially lost.
Nevermind, I'm a genius.
A camera!
Camera filters.
Potato chips from the jungle.
What
do I do with this?
It sells for 45.
If I use this, they will know probably, right?
Let's hide it within the barriers.
Can I just sell this at the store?
Can I just go to the store and say...
You wanna buy some of these?
We'll sell the mushrooms too.
They could call the cops on us.
We're hiding it amongst the berries.
So don't worry so much if you're scared.
Don't worry, we're hiding it.
Don't worry.
But it was mushrooms!
In forests and mountain areas, add one gas thr- That's not me!
What was I supposed to do?
We are tired.
Let's sleep until morning.
Next time, eat them, I guess.
I guess so, right?
Alright.
Stay in a hostel three times.
Comfortable.
Yeah, let's check my skills real quick.
This one, the social- Oh wait.
Getting perfect with this gives you the social status.
Cost is free!
You become happy.
Whenever you use a hitchhiker skill, this event restores one energy.
Good to see ya.
I never do this gain two armor.
I should start using it.
I should start using that.
And then I guess we can...
Wait, okay, let's see.
Move right and left.
Now you have access to the dog skills.
Need an extra space in the car for the dog.
Yeah, we have that one.
I think.
No longer have access to meat and dairy products from stores.
What?!
I don't have to follow your lifestyle, do I?
The dog has very nice fur.
And then our lady friend.
I guess we're fine, maybe.
Okay.
Give the coke to the dog.
What is wrong with you?!
My sister once had a friend.
They gave an illegal drug to their dog.
And I guess it worked differently.
I was a child, so I couldn't do anything about this.
But it like worked differently for...
You know, their dog.
And he just never came out of it.
And so he would always just...
He would always just stare in the corner.
I remember that.
Like he was just on like a permanent trip forever.
I didn't remember that until this moment.
Where are we going?
We're going to...
Tascow.
We're going to the big city, baby.
I think this might be the furthest we've made.
We've made it.
Repressed memory, probably.
Probably.
I think we do need to buy a concert ticket somewhere, yeah.
Or it was like you can also buy a tent.
That's optional though.
Hold on, it's in my... It's in our thing, no?
Yeah, we gotta get a ticket.
We go to Lompolis.
Wait, is it?
Yeah, we're on our way.
We just gotta follow the highway.
We're almost there.
We got this.
Someone might be getting kicked out.
Help me out, brother.
I've been running for 5 hours straight.
My legs can't hold me up no more.
I'm innocent.
Oh, this is the guy.
You gotta trust me.
This is the convict.
And he like steals your money.
Oh, nevermind.
Bye-bye.
We're Thalia's.
Thank you for 11 bucks.
Thank you.
Yeah, we got that guy on another one.
Oh, fine.
Whatever.
What were you saying?
Where did my happy go?
What just happened?
I looked away.
I looked at chat for 2 seconds and suddenly she's not happy.
ViviCore, thank you so much for the gift card!
Look, it's great being on the road, but I really miss being alone in the morning, running hot water in my hands, just staring into the bathroom mirror.
And you don't even know my name.
Our character is suddenly Venom.
Getting up, making some tea and listening to music with the sun on my face.
I like the tea.
Oh, the girl asked if you have some weed.
No way.
No girl, didn't you see?
We picked up the really strong stuff.
When a minute feels like a second and a second feels like a minute.
Wow, we're so happy.
Nice Volvo 240.
What are you, a car nerd?
You know exactly what it is just by looking at it?
Nerd.
Hot wheels.
Add one durability threat.
How much tape do we got?
Oh, this is our last tape.
Goodbye tape.
We're gonna have to stock up on some more stuff soon.
We'll get rid of this one.
And then we can use this one.
Takes one to know one.
Maybe.
What's a dog do?
Bark.
And then you're all that and you're all that.
What's the dog doing?
Oh, we're in the zone!
The dog has reached level two!
Oh my god, no way.
The dog is leveling up.
Wait, what does he do now?
What's the dog doing?
Traffic jam.
Holy moly.
Pet.
He's so innocent.
He's so cute.
We don't have any negatives.
But this one...
Let's just do it.
Dang it.
So close.
Hey dog.
No, we got a random one.
Take care of this one.
Is it?
Oh no, it's one out of two uses.
Oh my gosh, it's not even unlimited?
This is so messed up.
Wait, hold on.
I
pet the dog.
What is it?
What the?
Three more?
Stop.
Seriously?
Pet.
We're petting the dog.
And we're gonna use him.
There we go.
Good enough.
He's got two barks in him.
He's such a good boy.
He's so obedient and quiet.
Alright.
Can we actually use the coke?
That would be insane.
I'm taking a sip of coke.
You can use it.
Wait, what does it do?
Fully restores energy.
Gain the speeded status.
The money you guys.
The money.
Look at the money.
The goat in.
Okay, here we go.
Mushroom.
So I guess it's $45 to buy, but you only get $22.50.
If you sell it.
I can't sell it!
Sorry.
No.
I don't have anything to...
What?
I don't have anything to sell.
No.
I wasn't going to sell anything.
Sorry.
When I said, hey, I have coke to sell, I meant Coca-Cola.
I have...
I thought... I didn't say coke.
I said choke.
Like, hey, you want to...
You want to sell those hands?
That's what I said.
We're fine.
I don't know.
Are these...
I was going to say, are those beans?
But they're nuts.
Ah, nuts.
No, our pizza.
Our pizza.
How old...
Do you think this is still any good?
Our pizza.
Oh, let's put the cigarettes back in the glove compartment.
Those are important.
And the coke in the glove compartment.
Looking for... Oh, the black car.
That's us.
R60.
Where is that?
Where is R60?
R60... Wait.
No.
62?
7.
Where is it?
Everything is nonsense.
How are we supposed to...
Bottom left?
Oh, here.
We would have to go back, huh?
We're here.
We would have to go back over here.
What do you guys think?
You think it's worth it?
I actually have no much... I don't know at all what time it is.
Too far?
I think so too.
For only 60 bucks.
Let's see.
What do we want to do?
Forest watcher.
Watch over the forest.
Cabin cleaner.
That's it.
Of course we are going to go exploring.
Scary.
You think we'll find any special magazines?
Car.
We could find more Coca-Cola.
We might.
I'm so lost.
My energy is okay.
Where the hell are we?
I'm really deep.
I'm deep in it.
I'm neck deep.
I'm in the thick of it.
Into the thick of it.
I'm a little lost.
I'm in the thick of it.
We've been here before.
If I go down here.
I go down here.
And I jump over here.
Parkour.
And I go over here.
This is new territory.
I think.
And here.
Another rock?
Is that all that I can carry?
Maybe one more thing if I find it.
Also, I'm trying to find my way home.
I want to go home.
I can hold 5 max.
That's what it looks like.
I made it!
Make a random threat in the road events.
Gain the note warning.
We got scrap!
We got lots of scrap.
And more reading material.
More cigarettes.
Wait, what does it say?
Restore 2 durability?
We'll use that up.
Reduce gas.
Scrap?
I guess maybe this would be better to get than all the scrap.
And Groovy Jesus.
I like that we can't switch.
I know.
Look, it's alternating.
Ass, boobs, ass, boobs, ass.
We have such a pretty array.
Yay!
Converter is only for country roads.
Oh yeah, it does say country roads.
You're right.
What I'm trying to see is how I can sell it instead.
Maybe I just get rid of the scrap.
Look, we get 350 for it.
And we have 1, 2, 3, 4.
Calculator.
350.
We're really mathematizing now.
Times 4.
Oh, I'm sorry.
5 plus 350.
Is 1750.
And then this.
28 divided by 2.
Is 14.
Or 10.
Oh.
24 for the both of them.
So we could do 1750 or 24.
Yeah.
Let's eat some chips.
Goodbye scrap.
Let's see if I can make enough space to save some scrap.
Rotate.
Nope.
Discard.
Yup.
And we'll just sell those.
And what about Groovy Jesus?
It's the same amount.
Wait.
Discard.
Not that scrap.
Oh.
I'm an idiot.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh no.
Wait.
Let's do the chocolate.
What if I use the...
We are not stinky so...
I guess I could use the...
We're good.
There was one banana.
Alright.
Let's go sell it.
Some place.
Here.
Hello.
Take my Groovy Jesus.
Take my converter.
Take my scrap.
Take my...
Well actually...
Headlights.
I wonder if we could...
use it.
I don't know.
6.3 channel.
Thank you.
Welcome to membership.
Headlights look worth installing.
Depends on what other thing I have to replace it with.
Upgrade.
It would be...
Is it this one?
I hope it's this.
Right?
No.
It's engine.
It would probably be this, but the durability is too good, no?
Thank you!
Thank you for the 10 gifts.
I like my woman like how I like my cars.
Full of cars.
Let's buy...
this and drink it.
Nice.
I'm also gonna do some work.
Let's see.
8 hours...
24 hours and you only get paid 40?
But it's only 3 energy.
Okay, we'll do this and then we'll sleep.
Night falls.
We're dirty.
Now I'm dirty.
Now I'm stinky.
Now I'm disgusting and gross.
I'll use my toilet paper.
And now we sleep.
We're a little cold.
Oh wait, did I drink both the... Oops, sorry.
Did I drink both the coffees?
Oh, wrong place.
I did not use...
Okay, now we're just hungry.
Perfect.
Alright, let's get some more gas.
Good enough.
Nice.
On the road again.
I can't wait to get on the road again.
Let's go to fairies.
Fairies.
Very good fairies.
Wait, what's in Winga?
Winga.
What's there?
Money ying yang.
Thank you for the super chat.
Where is there?
What's here?
It's a mystery.
We can have a little detour, no?
Let's go.
Do you want an egg?
Sure.
Oh my gosh, did you guys see the...
The...
Popcorn bucket for...
For the Minecraft movie?
Oh sorry, it's not THE Minecraft movie.
It's A Minecraft movie.
And how it's like a TNT block, it's actually so cute.
Sunrisers.
Yeah, the TNT box.
I don't understand why they're so obsessed with the chicken jockey though.
There are billions of different faces.
And I feel like I've seen most of them before.
That's kind of weird.
It's like the simulation's random generator is busted.
There are so many weird faces, yet they are...
Always some version of a face I've seen before.
Sometimes I wonder if there are only so many types...
That just get slightly morphed.
Huh?
I think we took the...
The crack cocaine in our...
In our glove box.
The simulation's busted.
Or just lazily made.
No, we're stressed!
Oh man, I can't believe I thought about the Matrix.
I'm getting freaked out.
That's craziness.
I guess I really don't need this.
I'm gonna waste up the multi-spray.
Because with this we have unlimited things.
So I'm just gonna use this.
To get rid of stuff.
Do we have a single... Yes!
Single dog.
Uh-oh, wait.
We lost some gas.
Oh no.
Oh, we can use that one.
There we go.
Threat averted.
We lost so much gas actually.
Adapt changes though depending on the road.
Oh, does it?
I haven't noticed.
Oh, our music.
Sorry, I just keep playing the same thing.
Forest shadows?
Slenderman?
What does this mean?
What are... What is the threat?
The girl has reached level 2.
I can't believe the dog reached level 2 before the girl.
What just happened?
Spooky forest?
Thunderstorm?
Oh no, that one's scary.
Your shades came in clutch.
Fun!
Come on, dog.
Bark at it.
Bark!
Oh no.
Add one durability threat.
Bow-bow!
Bow-bow at it.
Let's do...
Okay, this might be a little overkill, but...
Three random threats.
There we go.
Oh my gas!
You are feeling tired.
Very tired.
Fix it on keeping your eyes open.
Slap yourself in the face.
Ouch!
You're awake.
We're awake now.
Oh, nevermind.
Plus tired.
We're here!
We made it.
To fairies.
When is it going to stop raining?
Winter tires.
Basic wheels.
Sport tires.
Remove one gas threat.
I want to kind of have one of those, but...
I guess it's fine.
Okay.
Time for the drugs.
Oh yes, this, this, this.
Oh yeah, see?
I knew I was going to do this down here.
I think this one is still better than the headlight.
At night, make a random threat on a row of events, gaining the note...
What is the note warning?
We don't even know what that is.
We don't even know!
Oh yeah, maybe he'll buy it.
Take it.
Hey buddy, I got the good stuff.
I'm not a cop.
I'm not planting this on you.
I won't arrest you immediately afterwards, because I found it on you.
I'm a good guy.
Welcome back.
Thanks Carl!
The musical one that removes adjacent threats.
Oh, but it's only at night.
Night.
That's fine.
Oh, black car.
R61.
That's not the same one as before.
Oh!
R61!
We're literally on the way to there.
We can make it, we can make it.
Let's get paid.
Make money, make money!
Freerun.
We're short on staff and need to deliver some pizzas to Freerun.
Elves get hungry.
Freerun is...
Freerun.
Wait, so if we go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
We could make both.
We could make both, I think.
Both jobs.
But what's the last job?
Freerun.
Lompolis.
I need beer for a party!
It's in 4 days!
Oh, we're also going there.
We could do all three.
Let's do it, let's do it.
Ok, this is not our pizza.
Wait, for the beer run too maybe?
Do I have to include the beer?
Beer is huge!
I have too many sexy magazines to include the beer.
I think.
Well, I didn't accept the beer one.
Right?
Forget the beer.
It's 60 bucks though.
Maybe I should have done...
How much money am I getting from the pizza delivery?
I don't remember.
Ah, man.
We're gonna explore and then we'll see.
I like exploring.
I like this part a lot.
It's pretty fun.
Mushroom, mushroom.
Mushroom, mushroom, mushroom.
I wonder how you get through the vines.
Maybe you need a cutter or something.
Thank god.
How do you say?
Something.
A knife.
Yeah, like a machete.
Am I back at the beginning?
I'm kinda lost.
This will lead to a rock.
I'm lost.
More mushroom.
I don't think you can eat the mushroom, can you?
Do you think you'll get a tummy ache if you eat too many?
Berries.
Berries go blue.
Where am I?
We made it!
We got a fender.
And some scrap.
And some more scrap.
And lots and lots of berries.
We got more food.
In fact, I'm just gonna eat that right now.
And we can sell these mushrooms and the scrap.
For the camera.
Can I just get rid of it?
Because it says...
Grants you access to change camera filters in the options menu.
Wait, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay, hold on.
I keep hoarding food.
I need to stop doing that.
It isn't useful in gameplay.
Yeah, I'm just kinda curious about it.
Wait, use.
Use?
Use.
Wait, what just happened to me?
Sad!
Double damage!
Uh-oh.
Guys, I don't think I should have eaten so many.
I ate too many.
I ate too many mushrooms.
I'm getting sadder.
Okay, don't eat the mushrooms.
I had a poisonous mushroom, I think.
I'm gonna need this toilet paper bad.
I'm gonna need it bad.
This one, though, restores energy.
So we'll eat the yellow ones.
Those ones are good.
Wait, what did I just do?
No, eat it.
Actually, let's eat and scrap.
And, wait, how much does this sell for?
10?
4?
4 and...
450.
850.
Oh wait, how do I fed it?
Oh, here we go.
Just like that.
And then we can tell it right now.
Sell.
Nice.
Jar of eggs!
Whoa!
Danish.
Tea.
Let's sleep.
Can we go to McDonald's, Minto?
No.
I have a headache.
Wait, aspirin!
Goodbye, headache.
And we're dirty.
And we're hungry.
Hungry?
No longer.
We are in TimTop shape.
I need to go to sleep tomorrow.
I gotta work early.
Goodnight, enjoy ghosts!
I'll watch the VOD later.
Aw, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright, I think we're good to continue onwards.
And we are headed to...
TimTown!
Oh no!
Sorry, we're going to Vinga, baby.
We're going to Mystery City.
Oh wait.
Some of those events were timed.
Majestic Falcon.
We're probably okay.
Your first play of this got me to buy a Game O and thank you Minto.
Yeah!
I'm glad you liked it.
Glad you liked it, yeah.
So awesome.
Oh, I guess...
That's kind of lame.
That was kind of lame because I...
I don't...
Oh, you don't have a thing yet.
Remove all status effects.
Become inspired and tired.
What does inspired do?
How did we get a headache and cold and everything?
What happened to us?
How did we become... How did we get another headache?
No!
I was in the middle of doing that!
Oh my god.
Okay...
The girl gives you a debuff for every buff?
I knew she was... I knew she was the worst.
She's also such a particular...
She gives me a back rub.
That's so messed up.
There we go.
We'll just get rid of all of it.
I don't care anymore.
My gas... Guys, warn me about my gas in case I...
I'm stressed.
I'm inspired.
Why am I inspired?
What am I stressed?
What's going on?
I'm gonna pet the dog.
I actually have no idea what inspired does.
Take powder to remove the stress.
No!
That'll make me more stressed.
It'll make me even more stressed.
Peer pressure.
More attacks this turn.
Let's just do this one.
Let's get rid of it.
Dog is almost leveled up.
Distracted.
Just... Stop?
You control this.
You don't have to be distracted.
What is saver?
What does that mean?
Nazo no status.
What does that even mean?
I'm distracted.
Bark!
I'm not distracted anymore.
I got barked at.
There we go.
You can check it by hovering in the mirror?
How in the mirror?
The girl is giving us negative statuses now.
She's not a girl's girl at all.
Why are you such a hater?
I'm just gonna use this one.
I feel like we should get this one out of the way.
It's kind of very situational.
You know what I mean?
Dog leveled up.
Okay.
The ocean.
Both calm and violent.
I wonder how long this lighthouse has been standing here.
One day I would like to set out to the sea.
Imagine being a lighthouse keeper.
I would like to set out to the sea.
Yo-ho!
A pirate's life for me.
Guys, if I wasn't a ghost maid...
Lose one energy after buying an item.
What?
This sucks!
We came here for nothing!
I once said though, if I wasn't a ghost maid, I would have wanted to be a pirate.
Pirate.
I like pirates.
Oh, I forgot that we can use the gas pedal too.
I'll have to remember that.
Alright, we're leaving.
We're heading back.
Oh wait, I forgot to sleep.
Maybe we'll be okay.
A ghost pirate?
Maybe.
I could be like the skellies on the Pirates of the Caribbean ride.
Sorry.
I'm so sick of these dang effects.
I should have slept or something.
No, it's probably fine.
Come on.
There we go.
Goodbye, Inspired.
I don't know why it disappeared.
I'm stressed.
That's the real truth.
Okay, perfect.
Oh my gosh.
We're sad.
Why are we sad?
The girl is too much of a pain after level 3.
I think I'm gonna get rid of her for real.
Can't take any extra turns during road events.
This sucks.
Oh my gosh, a tractor.
Look, we have so many negative effects.
Gas low.
Gas is low.
We're gonna speedrun this a little bit.
Do you die if you fail?
Actually, I don't.
I'm not quite sure.
Perfect.
Nice.
Gas light not on yet.
I think the blinking is it technically being on.
Why do we all have shades on?
Wait.
Why does the dog have shades?
I just noticed it.
It's so cute.
Hi.
Everybody is eepy but me.
Oh, they don't have the shades on anymore.
What was that?
Oh gosh, this is tricky.
This is kind of tricky.
Let's just do this.
Get rid of it.
Get me to town.
Allow me to sleep, please.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Use.
I think we would... I think we really would have run out.
Actually, I'm just gonna use it.
We can sell it afterwards.
What?
That was not half way.
Messed up.
How do we stop being sad?
No, you can't refill the jerry can.
Which is like really strange, no?
You think chocolate helps?
Vague lanes.
Kick the girl.
I will.
Great question.
Isn't that what we are all after?
Just wanting to stop being sad.
Oh my gosh, this is so frustrating.
This one is so annoying.
Am I gonna be able to get out of this?
Hold on, let's see.
And then I can use this one on this.
We would accept you just the same.
Pirate maid, you are still my oshi until you...
Until you get cancelled.
Oh no, that took a hit.
I'm getting cancelled.
I only have one left of these.
This is so bad.
Everybody is asleep.
Can you guys please wake up?
I'm in pretty dire straits, I'm not gonna lie.
I'm gonna do this and then I'm gonna use that one.
Oh my gosh, no!
Why did it add an extra one?
Wants to be a pirate and she is wearing a straw hat.
I'm king of the pirates baby.
What do I do?
Guys, what do I do?
I can't use the dog.
Hold the gas.
You are so right.
Which one is gas?
This one?
We made it!
Break.
Press to close any open menu.
It buys the game.
It would've just buys the game.
Oh it's closed.
It would've been fine.
We are tired.
Don't worry, we are gonna explore.
We are gonna have a great journey and then we will sleep.
We will sleep all through it baby.
Berries.
Such a lust for revenge.
I like the little hop, it's so cute.
Mushroom.
Actual stuff.
War.
They say a ghost haunts these wars.
I'm celebrating my birthday with Mindo and all of you guys!
Oh my gosh, Sami!
Happy birthday!
Hold on.
Let me make sure.
Let me just make sure I've cleared everything in here.
I'm watching my energy.
Yeah.
Back to this front.
Wait, I'm lost.
Guys, I'm really lost.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Samira!
Happy birthday!
It's okay.
We can still eat.
Or take in energy.
I'll just use that much.
I'm lost.
It was like in a strange little corner, no?
Oh gosh you guys, I'm really lost actually.
Did I come from this way?
I found it!
Oh my goodness.
We made it.
Let's go.
A new magazine!
More booty.
Literally.
My toilet paper is looking mighty sad right now.
I won't take any of the berries.
But I will take our new finds.
This is the optimal way to play this game everybody, okay?
Please understand that what I'm doing is recommended.
It's 100% the strat.
We have a lot of red berries so we'll get some blue berries.
I'm gonna make more money soon.
Thanks for always being here for us.
You get a new job Wally!
Wally for golly.
Congratulations!
She looks... Do you think she's cursing me because I have so much porn in my backseat?
She's really upset about it.
She's just like...
Yes!
Toss the jerry can.
Oh true, true true.
We can... The flashlight will sell first.
We already have one so we can just sell the other one.
Okay.
Throw it away, throw it away.
Sell.
And... I'm gonna sell the mushroom too.
And...
That should be good.
Let's go to sleep.
You're just a cultured, principled player.
When is it gonna stop raining?
This is the worst.
Alright, we're not dirty anymore at least.
Oh that's right.
I wanted to try... Okay, options, right?
Here?
Is this options?
K-chrome, J-one, Polaroid, Fuji... Wow, these are like actual cameras.
I'm selling the camera.
Thank you.
Give me money.
Okay.
Alright, let's go onwards.
We're going to...
Tim Tower!
Heya, Minto.
Heya, Duke.
What kind of music do you like?
Pretty much anything.
Let me see what you have.
Oh cool, this is Groovy.
Wait, do we get a new CD?
I wanna listen to Groovy.
Carvin, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much!
Photoshop will take a camera but not the coke.
What am I supposed to do with this anyway?
What do I... What do I do with that?
Behind large truck.
Use it.
I'm stressed.
I'm stressed behind the truck.
What kind of music do I like?
Anything.
Honestly though, I really do like just...
If I vibe with it, I don't mind it.
It's pretty much my philosophy.
What's threatening me?
Oh my god, finally!
Oh my god, it worked!
The dog has reached level 3!
And the girl has 2 maybe?
Same TBH, it depends on my mood.
Yeah, yeah, me too.
Speaking of music, dang it!
I wanted to play the music.
Can I put on some music?
I'm sad.
Why am I... Oh, because of the girl.
This girl is really souring my mood.
I'm sick of her!
Oh my gosh, fetch!
Fetch boy, fetch!
Can I kick her out or...
Can I just get her out of my car?
Yeah, you can?
Okay, good.
There's Debbie Downer over here.
I wish I had 2 blues.
I wish I had the spray can.
Oh man.
We're just gonna do the 3 random threats.
Since there were so many that were gonna hurt us.
Yeah, I think the dog...
I think the guy with the dog kind of like...
You have to...
You have to... What's the word?
Stick with it, you know?
Because obviously at first you're just like...
Oh my gosh, this dog takes up all this space and doesn't do anything.
But then he becomes good.
Oh, you're right!
It's not raining anymore!
Yippee!
You have to have patience with the dog.
You gotta invest in the punk.
Even though he's kind of a jerk.
Do dogs go to heaven?
Yeah, of course.
They're all good through and through.
Just bad owners.
Yeah, exactly.
Wait.
We just...
We just negated all of our...
Okay, it's time for you to leave.
Wait a second.
What is this?
When you gain a positive status, you also gain...
Oh yeah, it's time for you to leave.
Goodbye.
Is that her?
I just made her homeless, I think.
Sorry!
You're just too bad of a vibe.
You're just...
You're just not a lot of fun, okay?
Sorry!
It is definitely you.
Like, it's not like a...
It's not you, it's me.
Is this...
Interior.
Engine?
Whenever you remove a random threat...
A random amount of...
Whenever you remove a random amount of threat, remove one more...
We finally got stuff for the engine.
What do we have...
This is the roof.
Do we have anything in here for the roof?
Roof, roof, roof...
Oh wait, there's another.
There's another one.
Hold on, what's this?
When you play a skill from the driving skill tree, change a random threat to a note.
Also, portable stove.
Make certain food items inedible.
This is also an engine.
Increases max durability by 4 when you pass your turn.
Destroy one ra...
Destroy one random threat.
What?
And we got a roof!
Wait, this is awesome.
You guys, we got two upgrades we can do.
Hello?
And the winch.
Is this a winch?
We could cook the mushrooms?
No way, don't say that.
I like them raw.
Raw.
We have more space for berries!
Look at all these berries.
All this space for berries.
Okay, so we got that.
And then let's go back.
I don't know which engine to get though.
That's tough.
We finally have a... wait, utility?
I like improved brakes.
Wait, where's the improved brakes?
Carburetor?
Doesn't the carburetor synergize with punk?
Whenever you remove a random...
Oh, that's what it means.
So when I remove a random, like the three amount...
The only thing about that skill is he has it just only twice.
So, the circle.
Oh, this thing.
No, this is turbo.
Subwoofer?
That's speakers.
Boost the bass frequencies of music.
Very important, yeah.
We have an actual AC that we could get.
What is that?
Is this...
I can't tell if it replaces this or not.
AC might be kind of nice.
Because we get cold quite often though.
Get the AC.
How would you describe this game?
It's like Oregon Trail meets...
What's a roguelike?
AC would replace the Lurv, but it's probably worse.
I think so too.
Dave the Diver?
I don't... Maybe?
Bellatro?
I don't think this game is so much like Bellatro though.
But yeah.
Slay the Spire, maybe?
I haven't played it.
So I don't know.
I think I will get the AC.
I think we will upgrade.
Because we have the sunglasses, I don't think we need this.
It is nice having the plus 2 durability, but...
We've been pretty okay with how we've been.
Oh wait, I just noticed the roll cage.
Increases max durability by 4.
Oh, I see.
Oh,
here it is.
Increases max durability by 4 when you pass your turn destroyed.
I think maybe the improved breaks will be good.
Oh my gosh, we're finally...
Look at us guys, look at us.
We are killing it.
There we go.
No more cold, no more heat.
And I am gonna sell...
I see this in the shops all the time.
Literally, it's right there.
So I'm going to sell you.
Okay.
Alright.
We almost have a full...
We almost have a full back row of goodies.
We have...
We're sad.
Why are we so sad?
Oh, this is not our pizza, this is the quest pizza.
Don't get it, don't get it mistaken.
We have free pizza.
No, no, no, we're not gonna eat that.
Utility back.
Does nothing.
Oh, why would I buy it then?
For the aesthetics?
You black out while driving.
Oh, is that how it happens?
You've made so much more room in your car for porn.
I hope we don't get caught.
They would either be very concerned or they'd be like...
Okay, we're going to free run now.
Did I need to sleep?
Oh no, do you smell that?
She dropped the bomb.
BD, open all windows.
We got rid of the girl.
Tony, welcome to Mambo Ship.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Beyond journeys end.
Roadkill!
Oh no.
Why did we stop for the roadkill?
This is so messed up.
I don't understand this event at all.
Let's see.
Let's get rid of this.
Yeah.
Ouch.
Oh my gosh.
Free food.
Ewww.
Holy moly.
Dang it, I was hoping it would get rid of sad.
I was hoping it would get rid of sad.
So that we could have an extra turn.
We're brawling with the roadkill.
This is so stupid.
It's okay.
We're about to make some money.
So honestly, we'll just get to the town and sleep and deliver.
I think we'll be okay, actually.
We really...
Good girl.
Yeah, that's a good girl.
Here you go.
Take it.
What did you just give her?
Little dog?
Or big dog?
She didn't just give her the coke and all.
Okay, we still have it.
I'm happy I took this road.
Look out the door window.
The open fields that...
Nowhere.
The clouds, the sky and the color of it all.
Wow.
We gained nothing from that.
I don't miss real.
Oh there's the...
Wow.
There's the open fields.
Flock of sheep.
Oops, sorry.
Everybody else is running by them.
Use the dog.
Okay, thank goodness.
There we go.
Ouch.
Use the dog.
Actually, dog has no more for this one.
It's okay, we got...
It's okay, we'll be alright.
I'll use the cigarettes on this one.
Oh yeah, that's right, we get an extra turn now.
Yay!
I've smoked 14 cigarettes!
When using cigarettes, consume...
Two instead of one.
You got my pizza?
I'm so mad.
Why does this game hate me?
Pizza is my passion in life.
So true!
Why does he hate?
Why does this game hate me?
Hold on.
That was so weird.
Wait, hold on.
My phone started going crazy all of a sudden.
I'm okay.
I guess we don't need anything.
And let's just get some more gas.
Oops, my bad.
We can get up to like 75%.
There we go.
20 bucks.
Okay, and...
Next we have to go to...
Here.
What was here?
What was...
Oh wait, I gotta sleep first.
Maybe.
Sleep.
We're hungry.
No, no, no.
We're not hungry.
Do you know how many berries are in this truck?
Actually, we're running low on berries.
We're actually kind of running low.
But we have lots of pizza.
We have the most pizza.
You have to get to 61.
Yeah.
But what was this quest?
I don't remember.
61 is down here.
And Hungrad is where we get the concert ticket.
So honestly...
And then we just go up here.
And we're at the concert.
The festival.
So we're actually...
But what is here?
Punk club?
Eastern city.
Grandma?
I think she's dead.
61.
The great race.
We've...
Oh, wait.
We can get a ticket here.
We can get a ticket out here.
And find a tent along the way.
We've got this.
That was the beer mission.
I think you're right.
That's right.
If only I had the little card on top.
We would have been able to do it.
I think grandma is gone.
Wow, Esper.
Thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you.
Slow driving area.
Why is...
Why does this exist?
Hold on.
I'm gonna try this.
And...
Dog.
Bark.
We're losing gas.
OK.
And then...
Bam!
What did I get?
I'm hungry again?
Oh, I forgot the music.
Guys, I keep forgetting.
You can say something if I forget it.
Eat the banana.
Wait, hold on.
Eject!
Let's make a...
Let's make a shuffle tape.
There we go.
I keep saying it.
You keep not reading.
I keep playing the game!
I'm playing the game.
Wait.
Crystal boys.
That's a new one.
Wow, we're in the city.
Anyone remember the rip grandma default dance clip?
Wait, we're lost?
And all of my hitchhikers are asleep.
Oh my gosh, the question marks.
I'm lost.
Wait, is even the dog asleep?
Even the dog is asleep!
Oh no, wake up please!
I'm lost.
This is so silly.
I hope I don't get pulled over.
I didn't mean to.
Am I going to hell?
What does this mean?
Now we're fast and lost.
No, we're in the slow driving area.
That's the worst thing we want.
Wait, lose energy?
I couldn't read it.
It went away too fast.
Okay.
Cool.
Dog.
Bark.
I mean fetch.
Fetch.
And...
Bark.
All the hitchhikers are asleep.
It says it in the mirror.
Oh, that's right.
The mirror.
Energy cost decreased by 5.
Lose energy after road event.
Make this last.
Oh no.
Got it.
We're going for a jar of eggs.
And we are in the zone.
In the zone.
And we're in...
No, we're not in the zone anymore.
What is this?
Hello.
Good night, Minky and fellow Wisps.
Gonna watch the VOD tomorrow while I work.
Thanks for the stream.
Good luck with the drive.
Thanks, Jpax.
Oh, I got your ticket for the festival.
Festival.
Ticket to the Way Out Festival.
We got it!
This is the garage mechanic and this is the talking person.
Hey, wanna buy some nice stuff?
Dang it!
What do you mean he won't accept it?
We got worms.
We got worm graffiti.
A crowbar.
Graffiti.
Gun?
Better not get caught having it near us.
It's in red.
You guys, it's in...
It's scary.
What's this one?
Butterfly knife.
Oh, I thought it was a party popper.
Actually, the knife might come in handy for the roadkill.
What is the gun for?
Hopefully you'll never have to use it.
Why won't this guy take my...
He only wants to sell it.
He doesn't wanna...
Just combine it!
I like the green worm.
What is this one and this one?
Is this an upside down star?
I don't get this one either.
It's just an X?
How lazy.
Probably because it's a U.
I didn't mean to!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Let's put a...
This one.
Actually, I don't know what this one says either.
Let's put a purple worm.
Wait.
Let's put a green snake.
And the gun.
If we hide the gun on the rooftop...
Do you think it would be fine?
I am gonna get the crowbar.
And the knife.
This is our illegal stash.
Right?
Hide the coke up there too.
Illegal stash.
No,
no, no.
I'm not selling.
I was gonna try and move them all up in here.
But also they will get wet.
I'm scared you guys.
I get pulled over by the cops all the time.
What do I do?
We are so close to the end.
It's also very expensive.
I'm gonna... Sorry guys.
I'm gonna weenie out.
I'm sorry.
I'm weenieing out.
Oh.
Hey, hey.
Sorry.
You got some change?
One buck?
I can give a buck.
Appreciate it.
Oh.
You're welcome.
Explore?
This looks mighty... This place is huge also.
We have a hotel.
Oh cool.
We can sleep in there.
Employment.
Hi.
Are you also going to the festival?
You should totally check out this band that's playing there.
Oh, nice.
Zimmer Grandioso.
Nice.
Oh, thank you for the brain.
Salvi, thank you.
This place is humongous.
This car is insured, right?
Probably.
A tent!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
We have basically...
Can I rotate it?
An amplifier.
A book.
Spend some time reading.
When the book is finished, you might feel something.
Is that not a bible?
A tambourine!
A lucky cat!
Increases luck.
I need that.
Wait.
More books.
What is that book?
A knife.
A rooster with a jacket.
Do you like hurting people?
What does that mean?
Strong liquor.
Seems deep.
Seems popular.
I need the tent.
I guess I can't put it in here.
I have to put it in the trunk.
That sucks.
I hate that I can't move things from...
At least I have not figured out how I move things from my trunk into the top space.
What's Hotline Miami reference?
Oh a CD!
It's red as fwa.
Oh man!
No!
I thought it was K-On!
Fwa fwa time!
I don't want this!
Oh man!
So...Oh move!
Thank you guys!
So that's how you do it.
I wish I could...
Rotate.
And then move.
There we go.
Actually I don't think that made any difference.
But that's okay.
It made a difference in my brain.
I gotta go put this on my car for real.
Let's see.
It seems exciting.
Let's get the exciting book.
Or the pizza.
Nope.
That's our roommate.
Read.
Oh!
That takes a lot of time.
Hi.
I hope this reaches you as I do not know if you saw the last letter we sent.
I write now to regretfully inform you that your grandmother passed away last night at 5.21pm.
There was nothing we could do as the cancer had damaged so much internal tissue.
She left you a message concerning your inheritance.
The address is attached.
Dr. Vaswani.
Go to your land.
I have no other choice but...
My land!
It's so far!
Wait.
I have to go all the way back home?
Sorry Gramps.
I got a festival to go to.
I didn't...
Well, at least the shops are still open.
Let's see.
What else do we got around here?
We have a place to explore.
A bar.
Moscat!
Location in free run.
Our cat Cookie is missing!
I don't want to go back though.
I want to keep going forward in the beer run at Tascow.
Where is that?
We got to go down this way.
Oh, it's all the way back here?
Oh, hell no.
What is up with these weirdo...
These strange...
Beer runs and stuff.
Oh, it looks so bad.
Our car looks so dingy and horrible.
Can they... If I repair it, will they like...
Will they...
Clean it too?
It looks so ugly!
It looks so bad!
I just turned 30 yesterday.
Mind if I get a birthday greeting?
Happy birthday!
The beard?
Is that how you say my name?
Happy birthday!
The bar.
What do they sell?
Wait, what kind of food do they sell there?
Chicken wings.
Cures starving.
I mean, you know what?
Honestly, yeah.
A good fries can cure all.
Nuts.
Beer, beer, beer, beer.
Jar of eggs.
Explore.
Oh my god.
I might get shanked.
Sorry.
That's why I have the knife!
They were going to mug me, but I mugged them first.
This game is unbelievable a little bit.
I can't tell what is to be explored in, you know?
This game is a little wacky.
I mean, I knew that, but you know.
The crowbar!
Oh my god.
So that's why we needed those things.
Are we out of the countryside now?
So we don't really need the flashlight and that kind of stuff anymore?
Everything looks the same.
I can't tell where I'm at.
Wait.
No.
Hello.
I'm out of here.
This is so strange!
I think that's all there is to it.
I think so.
Excuse me.
What's home?
Where is home?
Where did I come from?
Where did I start from?
Where?
Is this here?
Oh, here.
OK.
We got it.
Seriously?
It's...
Oh my god.
OK.
Let's take these and see if we can sell them this time.
They're brand new!
Asterisk.
I have some...
Hey.
Hey, hey.
Are you kidding me for a minute?
What do I do with all this cocaine?
What do I do with it?
What do I do?
It's a good thing I got the knife.
Kid sniffing!
No!
Oh wow, there's lots of things.
Game tester?
Energy zero!
How much did we get?
$25.
To play video games?
I died.
Withdrawal?
I don't think...
Guys, I think I'm in trouble.
No, we don't need more.
We're OK.
We'll fight through it.
I'm clean.
I'm not clean.
We're happy and we're satisfied.
We're so good.
Everything's fine.
Everything's A-OK.
Don't worry about it.
I think I've explored pretty much everything that I want to in here.
Let's read our book.
To forget about our withdrawal symptoms.
Oh, we're not happy anymore.
Where is...
There was a market down here, no?
Yeah.
It is closed.
Just kidding.
Oh wait, about here.
There we go.
Beer o'clock, baby.
Fruit candy.
I like the steering wheel.
There's a lottery ticket too.
Oh, the jerry can.
Yes, that is definitely really good to have.
For sure.
No beer.
You guys were playing it safe, OK?
We're gonna get some nuts.
We're gonna forget about our troubles.
Get some cot... Oh wait.
Nevermind.
We're good.
Jerry can.
Fruit candy to go with your nose candies.
Stop it!
If I drink...
If I drink the coffee, you think it will offset the...
How did I touch... You guys...
I didn't even reach for the cocaine.
How did that happen?
No, no.
I think I am an addict.
I reached for the coffee and then I blacked out.
And then when I opened up my eyes again, it was cocaine!
Pull yourself together, Mito!
No, no, no.
There you go.
Coffee.
My hands are like shaking and I'm just like...
OK, it didn't get rid of my...
How do I get rid of the withdrawal symptoms?
Symptoms...
Just time, I think.
Do more drugs.
I'm clean!
Please!
Let's get out of this town.
It's a bad influence.
Soap!
Oh, this is actually good to have.
The espresso machine is calling to me.
Soap next to the doujins.
Yeah.
You can wash your hands after you're done.
Breathe in them.
Oh, the instant ramen!
Remember!
We couldn't...
So, remember there was a...
There was the pot.
The stove.
The portable stove.
I can't believe that the watermelon is one to one.
I can't believe that that is...
That is just a single use.
You just eat the entire thing.
It's craziness.
Alright, let's get out of here for real.
We gotta go make some more money.
F-ing trippy to be in the city.
Yeah, it's weird after being in the country for so long.
It's awesome.
But it's gotta suck living here, man.
Really?
You think he would like it?
We got a Zimmer Grandioso.
Perfect, we can listen to the whole CD.
Who doesn't eat it in one bite?
I'm clean.
I just have what...
He's not gonna see what's in my trunk, right?
Good thing I didn't get the gun, you guys.
Get
the gun.
Here's a random negative.
No more withdrawals!
Get me out of here.
See ya, coppers!
I'm gonna step on it for real.
Roadkill!
I lost some money, though.
It kinda sucks.
You have to choose, Minto.
Would you live in the city or live out in the countryside?
It depends on what city.
Like, I like Tokyo.
So I wouldn't mind living there, but...
I think generally I would wanna live in the countryside.
If I'm in, like, Tokyo, then I can go see idols, you know?
That's important.
But generally, I think I would... I'm a city... I'm a country gal.
Countryside but with good internet is the dream.
So true.
It's 4 AM.
What time... Wait.
When is the festival?
What day is it?
It doesn't say.
It's June 13th.
Oh, the calendar.
Thank you.
June 30th.
Oh my gosh, we have so much time!
Well, actually...
Might be kinda giddy-giddy.
We'll see.
I think it's gonna be giddy-giddy here, too.
Wait, so Hongrad... Hongrad is...
The punk club, no?
Yeah, so we'll go there.
Then we'll go upwards.
Film extra.
That's what we're heading to now.
I think we'll be okay.
I think we're gonna make it this time.
For real!
I can't get enough of these beautiful open roads.
I'm so happy that I can just drive around for a summer.
I never want to leave the road.
Yeah, I'm so happy I can just drive around!
Although it would be nice if someone else drove a bit, too, so I can look around more.
Fair.
I'm inspired.
What does inspired do?
Next energy cost is reduced to zero.
Countryside idols?
Not gonna lie, that's pretty good.
Who are you?
Hey, how are things?
It's been a while.
I don't know, dude.
I've been thinking about maybe settling down.
My grandpa bought some land out by the coast and maybe I should just, like, build a house there or something.
I don't know.
Stop wasting my time!
Three hours?
That's not so bad.
Countryside with vibrant internet.
My neighbors are cows and horses.
A tortoise tried to get into my house through the front door.
How fast was this tortoise?
No, we can't get gas here.
Oh, I do have a jerry can, though.
Damn the sun, it's too bright.
I like being on the road with you guys.
I think now that I have a new car, I would want to go on more road trips.
I'm lost!
Lost?
Uh-oh.
Nice.
Dog!
Sick him!
This isn't gonna be perfect, but that's okay.
Set all threat to attack.
A zombie!
My cyber truck.
Yeah.
Can a cyber truck even go on a road trip?
It feels kind of dangerous, though.
I've always wondered, how long does it take for an electric car like that to charge?
Like, are you just sitting in the parking lot for hours waiting for it to charge?
Oh, rough terrain.
Oh my god, not the tumbleweeds.
20 to 30 minutes, usually.
Okay, 30 minutes if it's a good one.
Okay, that could've... I was expecting so much worse.
I was like, this sucks.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, not nice.
I was hoping that it would get rid of it.
So then we could use him.
Oh, our gas!
Oh, I think we got saved by the armor.
We got saved by the armor.
We're okay, we're okay, we're okay.
Our armor saved us.
I haven't had to... Since we have two armor, I haven't had to, like...
I haven't had to, like, use the extra armor thing, so maybe I'll switch that out.
Turtle!
If there's a turtle in the middle of the road and you need to get him out of the way...
Why is he such a threat?
What you should do is you should move him onto the side of the road that he's trying to walk towards, you know?
Because otherwise, the little guy is just going to walk right back into the road.
So always keep that in mind.
I've moved many a turtle in my day.
But you're not helping the turtle.
Oh, why am I in the game?
Because I suck.
I'm a stinky person in this game, I guess.
Oh, it's a... Sorry, it's a Blade Runner joke?
Is it?
I don't remember it at all.
Let's get our money.
It's just the kind of car we need.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
This movie will be so amazing.
I believe you.
This guy again?
What's up?
Always happy to see my fellow road tripper.
I hope you never end up on the straight and narrow.
I mean sure, you'll have money and clean clothes, but like...
Fuck man, we need people like you.
Like me?
Freaks?
We need more freaks on the road.
Are we there yet?
Bald!
I wonder what I would look like bald with this hat on.
I think I have enough food.
I don't have anything to sell.
We haven't really gone exploring or anything.
I think we're good.
Let's get some gas and hit the road.
Oh, I almost had it at 25 exactly.
I was taking a drink.
Yeah, and...
Puncture!
Yes, at last!
I got the fan set perfectly.
Good strength, not too loud, and in all the right directions.
Maybe I should just... No, no, no, leave it.
It's perfect.
You put your hand to the fan and then hold over the controls, but refrain.
Oh, we're tired and hungry.
I just noticed.
We'll eat, we'll eat.
I like this music a lot.
Do not play with those settings.
I know!
You just said it was...
The ocean!
Aw man, we're getting bullied by... Do a kickflip!
Hey kids, it's me, Tony Hawk.
Why are they all a threat?
What is happening here?
See ya, kids.
On the highway, right?
It's so pretty!
This is making me wanna road trip so bad.
I wanna go on a road trip.
Dumpster diving.
Wait, we're going fishing?
Let's go.
This has been such a comfy stream to listen to while I work.
Thank you, Minto.
Of course!
Thank you.
Oh, we don't have what's-her-name anymore.
I
don't mind the energy threads so much.
I don't mind those ones so much.
So, bye!
Oh, I don't wanna... It's fine.
We're just gonna have to use it.
Wait, what's this one?
Hungry.
Oh, we're hungry.
What are we getting?
A Danish!
Oh my god.
Please.
Why is there so much?
Who's just throwing away all this cocaine?
I know I don't have to take it.
I'm saving it up, you guys, so that we can throw it in the mega dumpster.
No!
I'll drop it into the sea.
I'll let the fishies handle it.
Why is there...
Why is there so much?
Behind large truck.
Uh-oh, we're gonna get stressed again.
Mega dumpster of your nose.
No!
That'd be ridiculous.
Oh, this is perfect.
Oh my gosh.
I love when things work out like that.
Ouch.
The festival's gonna be so lit.
We're bringing it for all our friends, you know?
All of our friends.
Gonna have a crazy time.
Oh shoot, I just noticed I had the spray bottle.
My bad.
Oh, where were you?
Dog.
Pet.
That would be ridiculous because your nose is tiny.
Does it make your nose grow?
Take all the coke at once for a secret ending.
It makes it bleed?
Oh my god.
Wait, shouldn't it have gotten rid of...
Oh my god, there's a bee in our car!
Oh my god, we have a bee in our car!
It's okay, as soon as we get to the next place we're gonna rest.
I just noticed what the threat was.
I thought it was... I don't know what I thought it was.
I thought... Hello, please.
Bitch!
Wanderlust.
Okay, we're here.
Go to the punk club.
We'll sleep here too.
Caf cookie!
Oh, shop.
More jar of eggs.
Yeah, I'll take it.
I'll take the jar of eggs.
Yeah, I'll take that.
Where's the punk club?
Hotel?
Who are you?
Hey buddy, can you spare some change?
Yeah, I'll give you a dollar.
Appreciate it.
You're welcome.
I'm accumulating good karma.
Half food?
As opposed to what?
Boil a mashup, stick them in a stew!
What year is it?
You might want to grab some coffee.
We're gonna go to sleep I think.
I'm so psyched for the festival.
Oh, this is the guy that gives us the CD.
Our car is okay.
Wait, I do though customize.
Let's try a different paint, no?
Wait, what about the teal?
That's a mint-o-mobile if I've ever seen one before.
Grocery corner.
Beep boop.
Nothing of interest.
Please wash your car.
How do I wash it?
How do I wash the car?
Here?
At the repair?
Coffee break.
If I budget repair, will I still clean it?
My friend is a big fan of yours.
Could you sing him happy birthday when you get the chance?
I would love to!
Thank you for the superchat!
What's your friend's name?
Oh it's clean!
Yay!
So, I'm looking for this place called VCE.
Digital Equipment.
That's your friend's name?
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday digital equipment!
And if that's not your name you can blame your friend Tei for this.
Happy birthday!
I'm looking for this club called VCE.
It's somewhere around here.
Want to help me find it?
Oh, and can you take care of my dog?
I don't think she'll like... Oh, that's the guy.
I was wondering who we were talking to.
Did I find it?
Or why did I zoom away so fast?
I'm talking?
Grandma.
Back in the 60's me and my hubby got ourselves a beautiful car.
We did everything we could to keep it up to spec.
Not a dent.
Not a scratch.
We might as well have wrapped it in armor.
Gotta explore to find it.
OK.
There was an explore area actually though.
Enter the hotel.
We're gonna also do a job so we can make some more money.
So scary.
I don't like the streets.
I wasn't built for the streets!
Clear obstacles while exploring the city.
I'm a city kid.
There's nothing even here.
How much you wanna bet there's cocaine in that car?
You would think that cocaine grows on trees.
Actually...
Where does it come from?
Does it grow on trees?
Trees.
I saw the club.
Don't worry.
I'm just checking the other stuff first too.
The punk enters the club, leaving the dog with you.
I'm not cool enough for the club I guess.
Fine.
I'll take all my cocaine home with me.
Nobody will have it.
I'm not willing to share.
It's a processed leaf from a certain plant.
We got more pizza!
And a new suspension.
I told you so.
Discard.
Yeah, let's get rid of that.
I don't want a red car.
Sell the scrap.
Sell the suspension.
Nice.
So, is our guy gone?
Oh my gosh, I keep forgetting about our skill tree.
Let's see.
Remove one threat for each skill you use this event.
If you get it perfect with this skill, restore one use to all skills and gain 10...
10!
Did we just steal the dog?
We might have.
But I don't want to lose the guy.
He's been good to us.
Minto is for the maid cafe, not the streets.
Please drive me over in a coke-fueled rampage.
Become happy whenever you use a hitchhiker's skill this event.
Restore one energy.
Road trip!
Getting perfect with this gives you the social status.
If you're social, this costs nothing.
Wow.
Unlocking all skills in a tree gives bonus perk.
Well, I have.
Let's see.
What one would be easiest to unlock?
I guess this one.
I have a bunch of money.
It's the basic.
Working class hero.
When you use a basic skill, you have a 50% chance to become inspired.
Remove one threat for each...
Remove all armor.
I don't like that though.
Ignores shields.
Zero energy.
Gain one armor for each threat removed with this.
This is so specific.
Holy moly.
Huh.
Do you do menbucha happy birthdays?
I do!
Is it your birthday?
Serante.
Is that how you say your name?
Is it your birthday?
Love scout is good even when not perfect.
It gives armor per hit.
Really?
Okay, we'll add it then.
It is?
Okay, give me one second.
I'm gonna switch this one out actually.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Serante.
Happy birthday!
And wow, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Alrighty.
We are tired.
Trying to decide.
I mean obviously we need... What I'm gonna do...
What is illegal drugs?
No, I'm just kidding.
What I'm gonna do...
Two energy.
Let's go sell some stuff real quick.
Sell.
Do we have any more energy things in here?
Any coffee?
No?
Seriously?
No coffee?
Someone clip that.
No!
I'm gonna get arrested.
I'm gonna go to hell.
No, please.
I'm a good girl.
I promise.
I'm not doing drugs.
I've never done drugs.
I'm a good girl.
I'm clean.
Then we go into... Holy!
An antique store.
Tent roof rack.
Fully restore energy when resting in the car.
That's awesome.
Pedal board.
Several effect pedals rigged to a board.
No.
No more foie.
I know what you are.
You're a furry ass... Wiper?
What was it?
Furry...
Foie.
What was it?
Freaking world of ass.
I was like... I was like furry.
I forgot about the werewolf.
Instead of werewolf, I just changed it out with furry.
Foie, foie time.
What does the girl do anyway?
Our hula lady.
Portable stove.
Tent roof rack.
But we have to... We would lose the storage up here.
Which is... That's where we keep...
Some stuff.
In fact, that's where we'll be keeping all of our cocaine.
Don't mind... Don't mind this one.
I found it that way.
I didn't use it, okay?
So much cocaine.
I know, I just keep finding it.
Can I move the fog up front?
Fog?
Oh, the dog?
Can I move the dog up front?
Great question.
Wait, but I use the punk.
I use him a lot.
I'm kind of nervous now.
I use his skills a lot.
But...
It's not stackable?
I don't think so.
Nope.
It's not that I just noticed.
I noticed before.
I'm just lamenting about it again.
I'm nervous.
Find another person.
What's the dog doing?
He's chilling with us, I guess.
Was there anything in here?
Oh yeah.
Pizza delivery?
Time... Where is that?
Oh, it's not really.
It's kind of out of the way, huh?
We're here.
I'm going this way.
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I cannot... My mouse is really messing up.
And then this.
That one's easy.
Oh wait, is it already... No.
Hold on, I'm trying to find the...
Mechanic.
Is it already on there?
I can't see it over the graffiti.
Am I still gonna get paid?
As long as I'm still paid, it's fine.
No?
Actually, I really hate this one.
I'm gonna sell it.
Goodbye.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's me!
That's me, baby.
Alright, let's do a job.
Job.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Actually, was that chocolate?
Yes!
Chocolate?
Did you just say chocolate?
Chocolate!
Chocolate.
Job.
Gosh, we're so fast.
My eyes can't keep up.
Alright, we can be a toilet cleaner.
We could be...
A toilet cleaner for 14 hours.
Okay, we only have 4 energy.
10 energy.
2 energy.
I get 30 dollars.
5 energy.
No.
Bartender.
Give it to the dog.
No!
Why am I drunk?
How did this happen?
At least I'm in the city drunk.
Do bartenders get drunk on the job?
Is that common?
Some do.
They're not supposed to.
The good ones do.
We got a headache.
Oopsie.
Oh, we can cure this.
Nice.
At least I'm in the city drunk, she says.
I'm in masses of pedestrians.
Well, if they knew any better, they'd stay out of the road.
Now this is driving.
Alright, let's keep going now.
I think we're all good here.
Goodbye punk!
You know what?
I know we had our disagreances.
Wait, where am I going?
Oh, thank goodness.
We're going here.
I know we had our disagreances, but...
I really came to like you.
Is disagreances not a word?
What's a word?
We disagreed.
What's the word?
What am I thinking of?
Disagreements.
Guys, it's been a day for me.
I was combining, I think, grievances.
Happy lasts twice as long.
I was combining grievances and disagreements into disagreances.
Anyway.
Shut up.
I don't want to hear anymore.
Look at the dog.
Dog's chilling here.
Anyway.
You know any good bones?
I'm going to try and use that word more often.
If you do, people might look at you the same way you guys all reacted to me.
Might be like, what an idiot.
Go back to school.
Oh, music.
Thank you.
I like this band.
Birds that won't move.
Oh my god, the pigeons.
Why are the pigeons such a threat?
So if I do like this...
Oh my gosh, wait, this is the perfect scenario.
Wow!
That was awesome.
I like how our fetch has...
It's pretty good.
Birds straight up waiting for the last brain to move.
Why are the pigeons clawing like crows?
Don't worry about it.
Oh, we're not satisfied anymore.
I've lost!
Do you think we've talked to the dog?
Do you think we're just like, hey, what's up dog?
Wait.
We asked the dog, do you know of dog?
And the dog says, what's up dog?
We say, you!
You're the dog that's up in my beeswax.
None of your business.
Sorry I'm not too active.
Never apologize for that.
I wanted to say thank you for always helping to cheer me up.
You help to get me through work, which is why I have to watch the VODs instead of lives.
That's no worries.
Thank you for following.
Thank you so much for the superchat.
I really appreciate it.
I really don't read enough.
I wish I had time.
Don't minus two me!
Every time I try before bed I just fall asleep.
And plus tired sucks.
The humble up dog in the front seat.
You had a lot of literature back there.
Oh my god.
I thought he was gonna arrest the children.
Get off the highway children!
Oh wait, this works.
And we got money.
Let's go.
Dog?
I have to use this one.
Gosh, this would be the perfect setup for...
For the punk.
Give them the powder.
You guys are such maniacs.
You guys are absolute maniacs.
What's wrong with you?
Are we making it out of this one?
Okay, barely we're making it out.
But we're gonna get hit by the gas.
Please!
Actually, hold on.
I think it's time to jerry can just in case.
Just in case.
I have nothing else that I can use.
Nothing for gas.
Oh, E2?
Thank you.
Please, please.
E2, E2, E2.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you guys.
I can...
Is this gonna remove tire?
No.
We'll just keep going.
Introspection.
Jeez, my back is hurting from these seats.
I need to stretch a bit.
I should just do it now.
Yes, stretch.
Everybody, stretch break.
Arch your back, squeezer.
Your bum.
Squeeze your shoulder blades together and stretch it out.
That
one felt good.
We made it!
We made it.
Let's go.
What's this?
Oh, it's a shop.
Decrease all durability cost of skills by one.
How does that help?
Whenever you lose two or more energy during a road event, trigger the effect of your wheels.
Oh, JTI.
Rally spoiler.
Rough roads.
Make a random thread on the road event skin.
Oh, the note...
Wait, star decal!
Cheaters tag.
Bigger rack.
Bigger rack?
Is this a bigger rack?
7x4.
What's our current one?
Oh, it is bigger.
I gotta move my eggs.
I gotta make room for it, but I don't have any room.
Wait, we can sell the spoiler.
Spoiler?
Thank you for bringing me though.
I'm going right now, but my hotel TV has YouTube streaming, so that's nice!
Also, the dog is a budget hitchhiker.
Vanguist!
I hope you're okay.
I put the seat down.
I just saw you guys saying that too.
That's so funny.
We all thought it at the same time.
Are you guys mean?
Nice.
Now we... Wait, I bought this.
Is there a...
There's no place to put it on!
Guys, we messed up a little bit.
I might have messed up.
Oopsie!
It's fine.
The lost cat.
HomeGrad is so far away.
Just kidding.
Where am I?
Up here?
It's not that far.
Buy the jerry can.
Yes, thank you.
Mine is... Oh, it's low.
You know what I'm gonna use?
Sell.
Buy.
How
many days till the festival?
It's June 14th.
And I believe the festival is on the 30th.
So we have plenty of time.
But I have to find the cat.
Cat.
There's like no places to explore around here.
How am I tired?
Oh, nevermind.
I got rid of the tired.
Sorry, I misread it.
It's a random road event.
No, I think it was...
Here, I'm gonna... We'll go in a circle.
We'll go like boom, boom, boom.
And we'll hope that maybe we can find him.
You know?
How old is that pizza?
Pizza doesn't go bad.
It was a box event.
It was?
I'm lost.
Bark!
Why didn't I use my smokes?
I need to remember to use these.
Fetch!
I'm getting hungry.
Am I?
I'm hungry.
What do you mean that living off of berries and bananas is not enough?
What do you mean that we need more sustainable...
Excuse me, this is just ridiculous.
Eat the berries.
What's wrong with you?
What do you mean?
Happy White Day.
Oh, it is!
Well...
I got you guys something for Valentine's Day.
You know, White Day is when...
You guys reciprocate, you return what was given, you know?
So...
Thank you for the 10 gifts!
Rest in glitch bags, thank you.
So...
What are you getting me for, for White Day?
I have a brownie from the plane.
I'm gonna go get it.
Hold on!
I have a brownie from... I didn't... Hold on.
I'm gonna go get it.
What does that mean?
Let's try it.
Tonight will be a blood moon.
A lunar eclipse.
I'm going to go on a quick road trip to see it.
I noticed the moon earlier was so crazy actually.
I was like...
It looks so awesome.
The brownie smells good.
Is cocaine count for White Day?
Give you 5 bucks and a high five for White Day.
Also thanks for the rose.
My merch is non-existent, my singing is literally lethal.
So here's a soup bar.
What do you mean, merch?
Good morning, Minto.
Have a green... Thank you, Glendramon.
Good morning.
What kind of brownie?
I don't know, it's just whatever they gave on the plane.
It's more... It's more moist than I expected it to be.
It's yummy!
Yum!
For a plane brownie.
But it was like, sealed.
So...
It's brand is Bourbon.
Bourbon Noko Choco Brownie.
This.
Oishisa Gyutto!
Should we also sing in a raspy red dress as a White Day gift?
Maybe one.
Sorry, I didn't mean to make myself so small.
My chat was stuck.
The legal limit is like around 0.05, right?
I wonder what my limit is.
Could I drink like five beers and be okay to drive?
I feel like after one pint, I get tipsy.
I'm sure I could drink a whole bottle of vodka and be fine.
There's gotta be something to drink somewhere under the seats.
I'm an addict, through and through.
No way.
We manifested some strong liquor.
Oh my goodness, it was underneath all of our books.
It's been there the whole time.
White Day filled with Whisperabu.
Oh my gosh.
For the festival, we are gonna be the partiest person.
Everyone will wanna hang out with us.
At the party.
Probably forgot it.
No, we made this happen.
If you can dream it, you can achieve it.
If you think real hard, then you're hard.
And then you'll find liquor under your seat.
White Day Giri Choco!
I'll accept Giri Choco.
Hold on.
I want the music, but I guess we gotta wait for the music.
Did I just hear a minky?
An artist I'm working with insists I pay you and not them.
Can I get five big booms for Taku?
Happy White Day.
This money goes towards buying more cocaine.
That's why my hair is so white, you guys.
It's not naturally this color.
I'm just covered in dust and powder.
I'll give you five big booms for that.
Wait, hold on.
I gave six big booms.
Is it okay?
We got an extra boom.
The sound is annoying.
Let's keep...
Take a look.
It's in a book.
Now the artist owes me 20 dollars.
Who are you working with?
Thank you for all the superdivides, you guys.
You didn't have to for White Day.
I was just kidding, okay?
I was just kidding.
Let's do a... eject.
Let's do a shuffle.
Oh, you said Taku.
I'm an idiot.
I'm kidding.
Hey, I've had a lot of cocaine, okay?
I've had so much, literally my ears are bleeding.
Welcome to Mambusha.
Thank you.
White Day resub.
Because I hate you.
No hate.
That's why you're so giggly.
I just laugh at everything.
I can't help it.
It's raw with laughter.
I don't know what to do.
That's fine.
Hi, dog.
I convinced my girlfriend to start the Metal Gear series.
We got another boss!
Let's go!
It's one quiet hot dog.
It's because... I mean, I guess I could... Let's see.
If I adjust the music here.
Maybe like that.
Like that.
So quiet.
Now the don't know sounds will be louder.
I apologize.
I should have just done that from the start instead.
Cigarette.
There's a White Day text?
No.
I'm just going to use this one because it's very specific.
I can see the ocean.
Nevermind, it's gone.
Oh, no, I can still see the ocean.
Fish hotel.
Oh, star hotel.
I thought this said fish.
Oh, god.
Wow, a sleeping bag.
Passive.
Don't become cold when resting in your car.
We don't because we have an AC.
Fish hotel fish.
Oh my god, the stickers are too cute.
Matchi the Rock, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
I really, really appreciate it.
Gosh, why don't they sell any things that get rid of gas, you know?
Oh, there's like... Wait, where are we?
That's right, we're going in a triangle.
No, that's Lion.
How does triangle start again?
The Macross song.
I don't remember.
It's closed.
Oh, because it's 1AM.
Gas is still okay.
I'm surprised this place is still open.
Food mart.
I can get some more food.
What do we have?
We're tired and we're hungry.
I'll get some more food.
Oh wait, I don't need more food.
I have lots of pizza.
Papa...
Yes, yes, yes.
I remember now.
Thank you for the...
All you had to say was...
And I would have been like...
Let's sleep until morning.
Pizza isn't a food, it's a trophy.
Let's... Oh yeah, we ate.
We ate.
Alright, so we're searching for a cat.
We're searching, we're on the road looking for a little baby kitten.
Little guy, he's in the road, probably in a box.
If we get a box, we've got the cat.
Who gave this nerd a driver's license?
I'll have you know, I've never been in a car accident.
Hot holes.
Did you accept the cat quest?
Yes?
Did I?
I did, right?
Yeah, we'll check after.
Now I'm scared.
Now, I'm not quite sure.
Now, I have no idea.
Oh well, this might have all been a waste of time.
This might have all been a big ol' waste of time.
This has all been a big ol' waste of time.
Wait, where did the cat... Oh shoot.
Where was the cat at?
Starting to get a little snacksy.
I should check if there's something in the door pockets.
Swallow some extra saliva and be happy.
Who says snacksy?
You can just say snacky or hungry or anything else.
No, I'm gonna manifest something.
Rummage through the door sleeves.
We get berries!
We get nuts!
Aw nuts.
Didn't you not take it because it was too far away?
That was a different one.
This one we were going in a triangle.
In hopes of finding the cat.
I can't believe I messed that up.
I'm sorry guys.
So many gas things.
This is so difficult.
Oh...
Wait, let go please.
Thank you.
At least install the new roof rack.
Oh yeah, we'll get to the city and we'll be able to install it.
That's true.
I couldn't before.
What's our status?
Starving?
I haven't eaten anything.
It's okay.
We have berries.
And nuts.
There we go.
I'll give you a little bit of extra nuts.
Okay, we're back in the city.
Where are we?
We're in Karlo.
So, Kongrad was where the cat mission was supposed to end, but I think...
Wait.
Actually I'm confused.
I don't remember.
I have no idea actually.
We have so much more space for activities.
Let's see.
And then shop.
We'll just sell this, baby.
There's a lot of powder up there.
It's snow!
It's been a cold, frigid winter season.
It's not what you think.
It's just been quite chilly.
It's June.
Oh, you're right.
No.
It's in the mountains.
In the mountains it's always winter.
The carburetor.
We got the AC.
I think we're okay.
I do though want to look at our skills a little bit, because if we can find something that helps with gas...
I think that would be big news.
Oh, see like this.
This is big news!
Which one should we get rid of?
Maybe this one.
Get rid of this one.
There we go.
Perfect.
This one's kind of good too.
If you escape after using the skill, gain 3 armor.
This one has how many uses?
If you get a perfect with the skill, gain 1 gas.
Okay, cool.
Cost 3 gas.
Cost 1 less for each exhausted skill?
Like I'm tired?
Destroy 1 to 3 random threat.
Oh, this one's good too actually.
This one has 5 uses.
This one has 3 uses.
But we have more energy than we have anything else, you know what I mean?
1 gas, 3 uses.
Your skill has exhausted.
Oh, I think it means no more uses.
Ah, I see, I see.
So it was...
This one?
No, this one?
Cost 1 less for each... Ah, I see, I see, I see.
So after... Okay, okay.
Been lurking, vibing.
Well, half asleep, but should probably head to bed.
I'll catch the rest of the VOD later.
Have a good rest of the night and stream.
Thank you, Crow!
Thank you!
Okay.
I did want to get to the festival tonight.
I think we'll just skip the cat.
Kind of want to get at least an ending, you know what I mean?
I think we're good for now.
I think this is okay.
Actually, let's... Maybe it's playing it too safe, but let's switch this.
I think this one...
And this one is the threat.
Get gas.
I have...
Do I have a jerrycan?
I have a full jerrycan, but we can fill up, I suppose.
I'm starting to get sleepy.
How long has it been?
It's already been four hours.
Crazy.
We'll fill up.
We're below $100, but we're okay.
Let's... Wait, what am I?
I'm tired?
We'll sleep.
We're gonna go to the festival.
And we're hungry and we're dirty.
It's okay, we got soap.
And we got... What's hungry?
Hunger.
Alright.
Let's go.
Where are we going?
We'll just go in a circle.
Pizza?
I'll start eating the pizza once we're out of the smaller foods, because then we can free up space with the small one stuff, you know?
I've been driving this one more than my actual car.
I know, right?
I wonder if I'll forget everything I learned in school someday.
I hope I at least remember the psychology and philosophy classes.
I hope I remember physics and math.
I like some simple formulas at least.
Or will all the new thoughts I have push out the old?
B?
What's B?
I'm already starting to forget those.
F equals 2X?
Oh no.
We're distracted.
We're thinking about math.
We're thinking about math!
Hold on a second.
I'm also a little distracted.
Sorry.
Messages.
People.
Stuff.
Nice!
And...
Do this one.
Time flies when you're doing white powder on the car roof.
I feel like that would be a scene from a Joker movie, you know?
I'm doing powder on the roof!
Maybe a future one.
I don't think there will ever be a future Joker.
At least not in the Joker that we know.
Right?
Perhaps.
Why is there death on the children?
Let's get rid of that.
That seems important.
And we'll get rid of this one too.
Not that Joker.
What Joker?
What do you mean spoilers?
I never saw it.
Doesn't the guy not like the movie?
What do you mean spoilers?
If you're saying spoilers, you're saying spoilers!
Spoilers.
Spoilers the Joker.
I convinced my grandma to play MGS Snake Eater, but she keeps getting confused because she was alive during that time period, so she doesn't remember that stuff happened.
Stop confusing your grandma!
How many more of these do I have?
I just realized.
Also, I don't want to use them too much because of my durability, but...
Oh, one out of five left.
Okay.
I think I've been using it too willy-nilly.
Grandma will suddenly pull out that she was also some secret agent.
She'll be like...
Oh, Eva!
I haven't heard that name in a long time!
Adamska!
Joker 2 was final.
Oh, so it is the last movie?
Of the Joker, Joker?
Of the Jorker?
The Jorker.
This is a big city, right?
Let's go exploring.
I'm not afraid of anyone anymore.
I have a knife.
Did I just go in a big old circle?
Wait, do you think we can get our punk back?
Punk!
Punk, I miss you!
Punk, please!
Come back, Punk!
I miss you, Punk!
Punk!
Unfortunately, no.
That's the worst trade-off.
Here I was thinking like...
Oh, we get the dog and...
Um...
It's not so bad because you are so patient and you keep the dog and also the punk who is a bit of an asshole.
And then you get all the dog abilities and it's cool and it's all good.
And then he just leaves you.
A dog!
The punk's dog befriends the snarling dog!
I think that's a rare... Wait, I think we just got a... And it's for spray paint?
I'm gonna make lose it.
Here I thought we were about to get some awesome epic item.
Could only be obtained late game.
I am a little lost.
Dog maxing.
I'm a little lost.
Is this where the dog was?
No, this is where I was.
And then here.
Ravioli?
That does not need to be cooked.
I've eaten many, many of raw ravioli.
Beige spray.
I'm gonna sell all this.
Yellow spray.
Let's see.
What do we got in here?
A melodica!
That's fine.
Should we get another... A Buddha bouncer.
Very spiritual.
I have no creative message, but still wanted to super anyway.
So, hello.
Hi.
Hi, Ashes.
What do you mean, why?
Oh no, wait.
My chat froze.
Hold on, guys.
I'm so sorry.
My chat.
Hi.
I can see you.
I can see you, Tropius.
I always see you.
Okay.
Hi.
Let's see.
Oh, a mysterious book.
We're grabbing that for sure.
And we'll... Oh, I was gonna say we'll stay in the hotel tonight, but I don't think we've got enough money.
Ten.
I thought that was my actual phone.
I guess we can do a bartender job.
And...
Yeah, just make our way back.
Don't drink.
I'm not gonna get drunk.
I'm not a lightweight.
I'm drunk!
Everybody watch out.
I'm a crazed... I'm a crazed drunker on the road.
I hope there's no cops here.
I am the law.
My car also decided to crap out and now I need to get a new one.
Twinsies.
Oh, it's me.
What the heck?
What is with all the people?
What is with... What is this?
Did all the cars get together?
Where'd the hotel go?
Am I crazy?
No, I'm drunk.
Oh, here it is.
25 hours?
Excuse me.
I made a mistake.
We've literally wasted an entire day.
We had the best sleep of our lives.
Snake, let's have the best sleep of our lives.
Alright.
Only two more places.
Two more and then we're at the festival.
And it's the 17th and we need to get there.
Calendar.
Oh, we're so good.
We got this.
Easy peasy lemon squeezy.
If I get there, do I have to get there like on the day?
Thank you so much for the 50k.
Thank you.
Music, Dokka.
Shuffle.
7192 channel.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you so much.
Pause.
Hot dogs.
Oh, I just realized I saw my pin message unpin.
Oopsie.
Alright, let's see what we got going on here.
If I do this one...
It like literally gets everything but the one thing that will cause us harm.
But we have armor.
It's okay.
Hey, Miki.
Hi, chat.
Have a good stream.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's use you.
Welcome, welcome to Keep Driving.
It's a roguelike...
exploration car game.
Oh, what am I?
Am I hungry?
I'm hungry.
I'm gonna eat berries.
I'm out of berries!
I'm gonna eat nuts.
Eat large amounts of junk food.
Glutton?
Become hungry more often.
This game hates me.
What do you mean junk food?
I've been eating berries.
I've been eating berries for most of my life.
How are nuts junk food?
Like, I know they're kind of fatty, but that's a good, that's a genuine protein, okay?
Gosh.
This game.
Berries are junk.
I mean, it's better than like Twinkie.
Or this brownie I'm eating, for real.
Going to eat berries.
Berries, what?
I'm gonna eat berries ass.
Don't tell her I said that.
I'm gonna have to repair my car soon.
So many...
I like this song.
Is this the werewolves?
Is this the werewolf one?
Yeah?
You know what?
Durability be damned.
We'll just repair our car.
Oh yeah, there it is.
The werewolf asshole.
Borzoi.
We got our dog with us.
Well, he's not originally our dog.
We kind of... Well, I don't think... We didn't steal him.
But I don't think the guy thought we were gonna leave the city, you know?
He said watch over my dog and then we like ditched him.
So...
It's a little... It's a little funny.
It's a little funny.
Oh, berry.
Berries here?
Oh, you what?
Who snitched?
Huh?
Sorry, berry.
I didn't mean that.
I've just been stuck in the snow for too long.
The... The... The... The... Brain frost.
The permafrost.
The...
How do I say?
Oh my gosh, I keep losing money to the tolls.
That was such...
What
is it when you're... When you're... Oh, a banana.
When your stuff is... When you get frozen, you know?
That was bizarre.
I didn't even notice.
Frostbite!
Thank you.
Yeah, frostbite.
Almost a year.
No one else is going as slow as us.
Unlucky.
That is unlucky.
Oh, that is unlucky.
We'll have enough durability.
Surely.
I think we'll be okay.
Ouch.
Floor it.
Meow.
I'm following the rules.
I am.
My setup is not so great, I'll be honest.
I'm just barely scrapping by through all these fights, I feel.
We got money!
Let's go!
Oh yeah, we're so cooked.
This is not a repair center.
We're so cooked.
Okay, let me... Let's switch out some cards.
We'll replace this with this.
There we go.
What we had originally.
That should be okay.
Hello, windows.
Turn off reminders, thank you.
Did you know it takes 10 million bananas to die of radiation poisoning?
Oh yeah, that's what will kill you.
Yeah, the bananas will kill you.
But, why?
Is that making my thing go down?
Yes it is.
What?
But it's delicious!
Have you guys never had...
Have you guys never had ravioli just straight from the can?
It's so good!
I want to read more book, please.
It's mysterious.
No?
Like the... Like a chef boyardee.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You mean cold?
But why is it making his energy go down?
Like it's so bad.
This guy is a... And our food didn't even go away.
Guy is such a drama queen.
Hand ravioli is great, but it's not raw.
Did I say it was raw?
Um...
Is it 10 bucks no matter which one you choose?
Oh, I said raw.
Oh.
Alright, we got a skill point.
I failed the great race.
We are good on gas.
Oh, black car.
Wait, urgent help.
No money for gas need gas.
R72.
Oh, no.
Sorry.
I have no charity work today.
R76.
Oh, no.
What?
You guys... Was my car not good enough for you before?
Where are we?
We are going here.
There we go.
Let's go.
A bit far.
We have enough money.
I think we are fine.
It was so good they want you to come back.
We are so close.
We can't fail.
Have I unlocked all my available skills?
No.
Probably could.
You can't change skills while on the road.
Oh, I can't.
Something else?
Am I consumable?
Thank you.
We are going to... Not the journal.
We are going to put more... No!
I wanted to put a cigarette.
What is this?
This is so stupid.
I'm just going to use it.
Oh, wait.
Stop.
Nice.
My money.
I really like this song.
It's cute, right?
Very, very cute.
Oh, reliable.
Oh, reliable, baby.
Okay, now we can go into the trunk and we can move some stuff around.
Cigarette.
Oh, I forgot to sell these.
Oh, well.
I'll sell them next time.
Look!
You can see the ocean!
Construction area.
Oh, I think this one is new.
Oh, gosh.
This is like worst nightmare.
You get all those nails in your tires.
Let's do this, son.
Have a go.
Oh, reliable.
My favorite.
Oh, I should have used... It's okay.
The cigarettes are still there.
Yeah!
You know what?
I'm going to use this one.
You want to perfect with this skill and one gas.
Oh, we're not getting one gas.
Bandages?
Okay.
Oh, I guess I could have...
I could have like...
I always forget that the bandage doesn't make a... What's the word?
Doesn't use a turn.
You know what I mean?
Music in the game really gives the best vibes.
Wish the stereo upgrade didn't take up space.
Right!
I feel like... That was part of why I really wanted to play it though.
I was like, the music sounds so good in this.
And we are... Introspection.
No, we're behind a large truck.
And clear skies, yeah.
Nice and chill...
No...
That's so depressing.
But this one...
Nice!
There we go.
Increase following distance.
I know, why are we so close on his ass?
It makes me so nervous.
Like... I don't...
If he slams on the brakes...
This guy can't see us.
It's so over for us.
It's been so flooreded and all.
I have, I have floored it.
Yeah, I'm a certified...
Floorist.
Employment office.
Okay, we can repair.
Repair.
39.
Shaming customers.
That should be worth...
That's, that's worth everything.
Remember to sell too.
Thank you.
Let's get rid of this.
Get rid of this.
And yes, we're getting rid of the liquor too.
We're getting rid of the liquor.
Hmm...
If I beat this with all my porn magazines...
It might be the best to ever do it.
We'll just do a budget repair.
Okay, that was good.
Yeah, that was good.
You should sell the food too.
Sell all my food.
I worked so hard.
Honestly, I don't really need much else.
We're almost there.
I could like, well...
We could get the amp.
For the party.
No more foie.
I thought the books would like at least give us like a...
Skill something or unlock something, but...
Cause the way it's implied, it says...
When the book is finished, you might feel something.
I thought we would get like a skill.
Get the tent.
I don't need it.
We're one city away.
In fact, I'm gonna get the amp and we're gonna have a great time.
Wait, how much is this?
I'm... I... I am the party!
I am the party!
I'm bringing eggs, I'm bringing trumpets, I'm bringing pizza, I'm bringing porn, I'm bringing...
I'm bringing all the essentials, baby!
Baby!
Here we go!
To the festival!
Oh, I am hungry.
You're right.
Pull over!
Eat banana.
I should have slept.
Exit the menu?
Oh wait, I will.
Exit the menu.
Continue.
It auto-saves.
Sleep.
E.P.
time!
All is well.
Cowabunga.
Okay.
Here we go.
To the festival!
We've got this!
Use up my skill points.
I forgot.
Sorry.
Exit the menu!
No, just kidding.
It's okay.
Best plumbing... Flat tire!
I'm getting hungry.
This guy, all he does is eat.
What are you?
Human or something?
We can do either one.
Nice!
And...
No.
You.
Nice!
Let's do it!
Yeah, I'm a save scummer.
It wasn't my idea.
Someone told me to do it.
And I trust you guys and I listen to you guys.
Is that so wrong of me?
Is it so wrong of me to consider your inputs and say, Yeah, you know what, that's a good idea.
Yeah.
She loves us?
No, no, no.
Let's not, you know, get too hasty.
We're a bad influence.
We get this event a lot.
It's kind of boring at this point.
Get new material!
It's okay.
We have the armor.
I'm following the rules.
Nice!
And we get a gas.
We never have good ideas.
Sometimes you guys do, maybe.
The night falls.
Look at the ocean.
Why are kids playing at 10.15 at night on the highway?
These are ghost children.
What the hell?
Why are they here?
How do we wanna do this?
I wish I had put the gum in here.
Dang it.
Wait, I'm gonna use this.
Wait, this one.
Yeah.
Here.
Crafty.
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
Because the gum gets... Yeah, the gum gets rid of two things.
It's okay.
I'll just do this.
And I'll do this.
And then we'll take the hit.
Take the hit.
But we're gonna get more gas.
Oh, now we get a music note.
Real nice.
See ya, kids.
Where are your parents?
For real though, where are your parents?
We're hungry, so we're going to...
In fact, since I said that, well...
We'll get rid of this one.
Switch it out for the gum.
Get the banana.
Get rid of the banana.
Okay.
We're bringing pizza to the party.
We're bringing snow to the party.
We're bringing a winter wonderland to the party.
We're bringing Christmas to the party.
We're bringing toons... Oh, my toons.
My toons!
We're bringing toons to the party.
Tigers!
We're bringing a dog to the party.
This is like the ultimate.
Look at this.
This is the ultimate.
When did I become a drug lord?
How did this happen?
You know, sometimes life is just so funny.
Sometimes you're on your way to a festival and sometimes...
You become a drug lord on the way.
What do you mean leave?
I just got here!
Come back in the morning?
Oh, my god.
No way.
I'm gonna sleep in my car.
Good morning, festival!
I'm not dirty.
I'm squeaky clean.
I've got pizza.
Wait, I've got beans in my tummy.
I'm good.
This is gonna be the best night of my life!
Welcome to the Way Out East Festival.
May I see your ticket?
Perfect.
Have a blast!
All
the hippies are here!
Censor?
Is that my friend?
Hold on.
I have to see what else is around here.
We can leave the festival?
We can literally be like, nah, this is it.
You made it!
Park and let's set up your tent.
Festival!
Unlock ending festival!
The hour... I did not read pass.
The hours pass.
You drink, sing, dance and enjoy the few bands you were excited to see.
You are whirled from one scene to another, unaware of the passage of time, as you suddenly find yourself packing up your camp again.
The memories not yet formed last you a lifetime.
Developed into a kaleidoscope of sunshine, warm beer and constant noise.
I'm so young, young, young, young.
Keep driving.
Unlock the new starting loadout.
Festival kit.
I'm so young, young, young, young.
Please don't talk to me while I... Wait.
Please don't talk to me.
I fall in love so easily.
What a title.
Light novel title reel.
By My Darling You.
Is that this song?
Oh yeah!
Please don't look at me.
This is so relatable.
Don't look at me.
Don't talk to me.
Don't even acknowledge me.
Don't ever say hi to me.
Don't even talk to me.
Don't ever look at me and try not to sniff me.
Don't ever even say hello to me.
If you play again, I hope you go for the mountain ending.
It's my favorite.
I've got mountain ending.
That was so fun.
I hope you guys liked it.
Maybe we can try for some of the other endings in the future.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on, something got messed up.
Oh, that's the game.
Takes one to know one.
Okay, good enough.
Thank you.
Late night Minto hits different.
Thanks so much.
This is such a good late night stream or game to stream.
No, like...
Just if it has those late night... I wish I had done a build that would allow more for the late night drive stuff.
I love taking night walks.
Thanks for the stream.
Been a while since I can watch start to finish.
Thank you!
Did you ever say why your name is now Daybrid instead of David?
Nice way to stay up for the eclipse.
You have!
You're gonna watch the eclipse.
Enjoy it.
Never thought driving around in a car full of illegal drugs would be so comfy.
I'm like the comfiest drug dealer ever, maybe.
Breaking bad?
No, breaking...
Happy.
Good one.
I was working on something for White Day, but like my Kamiyoshi, I'm always fashionably late.
I'm not fashionably late!
I was late today because I bought a car, okay?
Had a great time chilling with Minto and the Wisps tonight.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you!
Whoa, Chidon-chan, I didn't even recognize you.
I didn't even recognize you!
Happy White Woman Day, Minto.
That's not what today is.
I just wanted to go back to Titanium without losing my peepee.
I think you wouldn't lose that so easily.
I think...
I think you're okay.
Breaking good?
Breaking...
Yeah.
No breaking.
We're chilling good.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Your stream of this convinced me to get the game and I had a blast.
Yay!
I'm glad.
Wow, thank you so much for the rose.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Detachable peepee.
Oh no, one zipper accident.
Is that real?
No, it's not that strong.
Maybe if you aggressively... If you were like the fastest ever to zip up your pants.
Kurisu, thank you for the membership.
Welcome.
You can... Oh wait, we need a third...
Keep driving stream so you can use the car's Minto art for the thumbnail.
Oh my gosh, Maple.
I love my car... Oh wait, I like my car like I like my women.
Optimus Prime.
So true.
You might need stitches.
Saitama zipping his pants.
Does that... It can get stuck?
I was gonna say, does it ever?
I think it would only get stuck if you don't wear underwear.
So, honestly, you're the problem.
You're the problem.
Always wear your underwear.
Thanks for the stream and thank you for all you do, Minto.
I'm happy to call you Mayoshi.
Thank you, Mr. Yumyum.
Such a cute name.
Mr. Yumyum.
Yumyumyumyum...
And don't talk to me and don't look at me.
And don't say hi to me and don't look at me.
And try not to sniff me and don't come my way.
And don't wave at me and don't ever say hi.
And don't acknowledge me and don't ever, ever, ever, ever...
Exist in my presence.
Next karaoke.
Murphy, thank you for the superchat.
Thanks for the fun stream while I was checking work.
Thank you, Cathy and Doug.
Good luck with work.
It was so fun to watch and now I have a nice soundtrack.
The songs though are so good, no?
Appreciate that the sniffing is only a try.
I'm glad you noticed.
Zipper on the crotch feels like someone... Oh my gosh, I don't wanna... Don't describe it.
Sometimes I get stuck on the hot dog.
That's not a hot dog moment.
They were all original?
The songs?
No, no.
I don't think so.
I think they were all...
Like indie bands though.
So, sniff a try.
Did you?
Did you, Junna?
Okay, I'm gonna go to bed now.
Thank you guys!
Thank you guys for keep driving and I hope you had fun and sorry I was late.
But... If you're watching the VOD then it doesn't really matter.
But I definitely did not expect to stream until 1 AM my time.
So...
Yeah.
Tomorrow is Devil May Cry 4.
And...
What time am I streaming on?
I check?
I'm checking, I'm checking.
I'm checking, I'm checking, I'm checking.
I'm streaming at...
6 PM.
Really?
Oh yeah, 6 PM.
Okay.
Otsumito!
6 PM my time.
Itterasshai!
Thank you everybody!
Bye bye!
I forgot to say.
I want to say also thank you guys for all the encouragement about my car.
Thank you.
I was really scared.
I was really nervous.
Especially because it was scary going to a car dealership.
So thank you!
Good job being brave.
Thank you!
Thanks for when I said...
When I said...
Say that you...
When I said no to...
Not compliment.
When I...
When I was like...
For some reason I can only think of the Japanese...
Because I did a good job and you guys did.
Thank you!